e
morning um welcome to
Monday um and we have several bills um
this
morning and uh the first is uh HB 12 9
relative to the definition of the term
evidence-based within public education
and uh Prime sponsor representative
beler is here and welcome
back thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the
committee I am happy to be here to
introduce this bill as a Verbatim uh
copy of what was brought before this
Committee in the last
session this oh apologies for the record
represent of the beler Carol County
District 4 out of Wakefield and I will
should have pink cards
already so this bill got a somewhat
favorable hearing the last time around
we came out of committee uh no um
opinion going to the floor and I do hope
we can do a little better this time but
I'm happy to take uh all of your
questions at the end it is a fairly
currently federal law um and rules
Define the term
evidence-based but they don't adequately
Define what the evidence in
evidence-based actually
is this leads to problems um in terms of
ensuring that the evidence we're dealing
with actually reflects the reality or
the facts on the ground as to what is
actually occurring
under the current
Paradigm objective evidence such as a
controlled study demonstrating increased
proficiency and better test scores is
given the same weight as a mere survey
asking administrators how they feel
about the efficacy of a
technique the first set of data is
objective and it represents good science
the second set of data is is
subjective and it represents not very
good science at all
presently teaching methods often are
legitimated utilizing the second
methodology of bad science they're often
legitimized using surveys instead of
objective
data when the data we're using to
evaluate is subjective bad science it
doesn't correspond to reality it or at
least it doesn't necessarily correspond
to reality and when it doesn't we wind
up with things like kids who can't read
properly this bill simply firms up that
definition of evidence to require that
the evidence we're using be good
I will note here that this only uh works
with pedagogy it doesn't cover subject
materials so there would no this bill
doesn't speak at all to what may be
taught in a classro it only speaks to
how we ought to be going about teaching
things in a classroom so it's about
material not only can we reasonably
expect
that this change in definition would
bring positive effects in student
learning and
proficiency we also stand to see
significant cost savings if we were to
implement
this anyone with a background in
education probably understands the
frequency with which fads wind up
getting chased in the field people want
to conform to the current thing the
current in thing and best of the best
field and this also legitimizes the
publication of new texts on an ongoing
regular basis and the cost of
retraining by properly amending the
definition we can significantly curtail
this fad chasing within the field of
Education by doing so we limit the
degree to which publishing of new
materials and retraining becomes
necessary in the field as we gravitate
more toward effective efficient ways of
doing business and teaching we get away
from fad
chasing uh lastly to the fiscal note I I
don't doubt that there might be some
small cost in implementing this
especially right off the bat um I don't
think it's probably necessary to have an
additional person involved because the
department is already doing this they're
already applying the rules from the
federal government on evidence-based uh
education this simply tweaks the
definition to make it a little firmer so
it's already something that's done uh
and I don't think it would be too
difficult to kick it up a higher gear
and continue doing it uh with this new
definition in place and with that I'm
happy to take
questions questions from the
committee represent Woodcock thank you
chair welcome repres Al good to see you
back again um like on the physical not I
agree with you
uh it seems to me most of the physical
notes that we receive from doe it's must
be an automatic placeholder it's
throwing another staff for another
$150,000 no matter what the issue is um
so I agree with you on that piece
however moving to the main text of the
bill um can you just explain to me a
little more clarity what you mean that
it it's only pedagogy and not subject
material yes thank you for that question
I'd be happy to to delve into that so
it's a matter of when you teaching let's
say we're teaching um we're teaching
reading it doesn't have anything to do
with what reading materials can be
brought in it doesn't say this book over
that book or this text over that text
nothing of that kind it only affects the
manner in which the book is being taught
so for instance for those of you may be
familiar with the concept of queuing
well it it appears from my best
understanding of the science that the
queuing method of reading has been
largely discredited by good
science but it remains in many cases a
method that's utilized and perhaps
there's occasional methods where or
occasional times where it's useful I'm
not entirely sure but there are newer
methods utilizing um more phonics based
approaches that are more classical
really that have been demonstrated
according to my understanding of the
science to be more efficacious more
useful so in both in both ways you would
potentially be looking at the same book
the same material it's just about how
it's being taught queing method versus
phonics so this would not affect the
material it only affects the methods and
in order to qualify all that you have to
be able to show is good science
demonstrating that the method works and
that shouldn't be difficult at all
because we have colleges of Education
all across this country constantly doing
scientific studies looking at different
different pedagogical methods uh and
legitimizing them
via largely good science I'm sure
there's some bad stuff in there too but
largely good science so it shouldn't be
hard to find good methods that we can
science thanks chairman um on a
different topic thank you by the way
Mike on that different topic the fs in
education um sort of like the fs and
clothing my father always say don't
throw your ties away because the skinny
ones will be back okay but that being
said the fat and educ what is the
difference between a fat and education
and
Improvement uh in instruction and things
that have changed because we've done
Empirical research and we see this may
be or we want to find out if we can do a
better job by changing the way the box
is
built thank you and that's an excellent
question um so what we're dealing with
is is two methods of sort of
legitimating or saying this is the
reason this is true and correct on one
hand we have these sort of socially
negotiated method on the other hand we
had a science B based method on the
socially determined side of things is
where we get the concept generally of
fats that generally are adopted not
because they're being proven to be
efficacious but they're being adopted
because they're being adopted by other
people so everybody kind of jumps on the
bad bandwagon and tends to do the same
kind of thing now that doesn't
necessarily mean that all fads are bad
because you could have a fad toward
something that's science-driven in which
cas there's nothing wrong with that but
the concept of a fat generally is sort
of scattershot maybe it hits maybe it
misses but when we bring good science in
we don't have to miss thank
you yes representative seling thank you
so much and thank you for taking my
question I'm I'm just processing your
your information and I'm curious I think
back to when I was teaching kindergarten
and how you know I was in a situation
where I was able to teach all of my
students individually because we team
teaching so that I could teach reading
for example or math based on how each
individual student learned and I'm
trying to understand how that which I
guess you would say some of the methods
I Ed were not evidence-based because
they were what was developing then for
students who didn't particularly do well
with for example phonics based
instruction but needed whole language
instruction which is a totally different
reading strategy versus an organ gillium
approach and so I'm trying to figure out
how that relates to this
term and also what
falsifiability
means thank you for the question that
that is an excellent question I was a
bit remiss in actually not covering that
in my introduction um
so the the scope of this bill is looking
to affect things that are adopted at the
level of the school boards and the state
it is not meant to jump into the
individual teachers classroom and tell
them that they can or cannot do X Y or Z
it actually specifically exempts
individual teachers and in individual
classrooms from the requirements of the
bill they can they if they feel there's
necess a necessity to do something they
can do it they don't have to justify it
based on the requirements of this bill
in terms of evidencebased they can just
do it um and I think that flexibility is
necessary and I think it's good um in
terms of the falsifiability that's a
it's it's a it's a term within the
scientific field of study that suggests
that whatever the proposition is you
have to be able to do some sort of
Investigation scientific analysis to
determine whether or not it's false you
can't always prove something true but
you ought to be able to prove things are
false um so just a simple 10,000 foot
view you should be able to undertake a
scientific method-based approach to
determine what reading method works the
best for the largest group of
individuals maybe not universally but
you could say okay which works best and
if a method is bad you should be able to
show scientifically that okay this
doesn't really work but things that
aren't falsifiable would be like
um big claims that have to do with
metaphysics um and certain
epistemological claims like
um
uh dealing with religion and things of
that nature so it sets aside things that
are not
falsifiable um in terms of things that
are falsifiable and things that are
falsifiable are necessarily items that
method for the questions yes
representative Freeman thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
bringing this in front of us um for
those of us who want educate is I
appreciate the fact that you're breaking
this down into more Layman's language um
my question to you would uh is that um
would the state standardized testing
qualify as a scientific study
thank you um for the question the the
testing in itself is not a scientific
study because it's not designed as a
study but it could be a portion of a
scientific study so and I and I expect
it often is the portion of a scientific
study where College of Education or some
organization will undertake a study that
looks at okay this is we're going to
make this change we're going to attempt
to design this study to control for all
of these uh other variables that that
impact it and we're going to have our
measurement based on uh test scores and
you can put those together and if the
study is is welld designed you can you
can reasonably correlate the change to
the test scores so yes in that
way yes representative welcome
back or welcome to this committee anyway
thank you thank you for taking my
question if I understood you correctly
when you were responding to repres
representative Sal's
query you're indicating that the bill
applies to boards and
state
um efforts not to individual
teachers can you direct me where in the
bill we can understand that it doesn't
apply to individual teachers I'm not
perceiving that uh yes give me just a
yeah so if you look at under um Roman
numeral one it identifies the scope to
who this um is applying and it it
defines educator training policies and
any ped pedagogical methods attached to
or accompaning
curriculum adopted by the Department of
Education local school districts and any
other regulatory body that may prescribe
teaching methods so specifically left
out of that was individual teachers
Within their
classrooms follow thank
you so I appreciate you highlighting
that and I would be
concerned that by not actually stating
that it doesn't apply to individual
so thank you representive
Cornell so in fact if a school district
passed um
ways of how they want things taught and
a teacher decided no I'm not going to do
that um because this works better isn't
that teacher opening themselves up to
being insubordinate or not following
rules and being
reprimanded thank you uh I I would
imagine so um this bill does not seek to
at all touch the educator code of uh
conduct or any sort of practices within
the district regarding that um this
simply says that under this bill that
would be allowable the school school
boards are certainly authorized on their
own to decide if something steps outside
of the scope of what they consider
reasonable thank you um I had one
question um You referred to Roman uh
numeral one um where it indicates that
the content the curriculum is not um
impacted by this requirement um but in
Roman 4 it says that districts shall
make scientific studies um available and
If the curriculum provider is a third
party the department may require the
provider the curriculum provider to
furnish studies that the that they are
uh evidencebased so it sounds like you
are in Roman 4 talking about curriculum
requirements thank you for the question
and this is that little bit of a area
where there's a small overlap that
occurs between pedagogi and curriculum
and that occurs because uh textbook
providers for instance will often
include um not merely material but they
will include uh instruction guidance for
how to go about teaching something and
if they're going to be including such
instruction guidance that is PED
uh pedagogy as opposed to content so it
would fall under the scope of this bill
and rather than requiring that the local
body go out and find the studies they
this simply authorizes them to go to
that Textbook Company and require them
to furnish them with whatever studies
they used to legitimize placing that
within those
texts and if um the uh provider does not
want to include uh
uh provide information to a little old
Governor when we're School District um
what is the um
result that's a very good question I
from my understanding in textbooks which
is not huge but there's some um they
don't just tend to willy-nilly pick
things and to throw in there that are
not being associated with some formal
method of pedagogy and as long as there
is that formal method of pedagogy
there's going to be scientific um
evidence and scientific studies for it
that can be pointed to if they choose
not
to then the um adopting uh department or
SAU would certainly have the recourse of
of going elsewhere or coming to this
body for any sort of
um additional requirements down the road
yes representative Corell um to get back
to the fiscal no um I agree that maybe
it won't cost um the doe another person
to do it although I know that they have
a lot to do but it does say the
department States this will increase
local expenditures by an indeterminable
amount um in 2026 in each year
thereafter so isn't this just another
bill downshifting cost to the local
taxpayers which is something that we
really are trying not to do because I
know my my property taxes went up a a
lot and this will just increase my
property taxes again if it has to be
absorbed by the towns and the
cities uh thank you for the question I
would say um no and no no on two fronts
so first of all the idea I I'm not sure
I necessarily agree with the idea of
downshifting because um we're talking
about money that's coming out of the
pockets of taxpayers whether it goes to
the state first then the locality or the
locality it's it's it's still the tax
that's covering the cost of education
but to go a little more in in depth on
the why what we're looking at here is
the reason that you might not be able to
determine immediate cost is because they
can't be 100% certain how many methods
that are currently in use might not be
science-based which frankly seems like a
pretty good reason to spend a little bit
of money if we need to to update our
methods to bring them in line with the
latest science in order to make the best
children represent
Damon thank you again Mr chair and thank
you for taking my
question I'm wondering how this
would apply or
affect the actual research process so
for example if
UNH is doing pedagogy research which I
believe they do and they need students
to do that research
with probably those students are
receiving education through the public
school system that you're directing this
at so are they then curtailed from doing
the research that you're promoting as
the premise for this bill
because the science of that particular
pedagogy has not yet been established
that's the point of the re SE
Arch thank you for the question I would
say first no it really is not looking to
restrict the ability to conduct research
in in any way however to get specific to
the point you're making I would suggest
that if there is any entity making a
suggestion that we make a significant
departure from accepted best practices
and standards um in our public school
students in order to conduct a study on
them we ought to have some reason to
believe that that's going to work that
can be pointed to and say this is some
good evidence that suggests this ought
to work um otherwise we're just kind of
treating kids like Lab Rats which is not
an ethical thing I would
think
follow so where and how does that I'll
call it preliminary research happened to
establish enough evidence that then it
would fit your standard for what could
um be researched with the students thank
you so we're getting into some some
really um important detailed but they're
also sort of edge cases what I would say
first is that the the totality of the
body of of uh evidence that's out there
is so significant it's so large that you
generally ought to be able to point to
some studies that say if if the if what
you're trying to do is legitimate in any
way you really should be able to point
to some studies to say okay this looks
like we a method we should be utilizing
for this reason and in such cases where
you can point to such evidence you
should be able to proceed with the um
with the research um as far as trying to
concoct really you know different
thinking kind of stuff
um that is going to be something that I
would argue shouldn't be just broadly
inflicted upon public school students
when we don't know what what kind of
outcomes we're going to expect we have
such a broad um body of evidence to draw
from at this point that we can look and
find good methods within what exists and
then take the next steps that take the
current evidence and take steps Beyond
it without completely trying to reinvent
the wheel and and potentially do great
harm to
students repr s thank you and thank
sorry it takes me a little while
sometimes to process all the questions
I'm curious whether the state has um the
state department of education has
approved curriculum that you would
consider not
evidence-based and and how you would
determine that from all of the various
curriculum they've approved from K
12 thank you are there currently things
fit yes that the state has approved that
do not specifically fit this I can't be
100% certain I do know in my own
research that there are broadly some
Fields within education that Trend more
toward subjective analysis than
objective analysis in terms of
legitimating certain techniques and
different teaching methods um but as far
as determining that down the road I'm
not going to be doing it um there is
some oversight capacity clearly within
this body to be able to watch over that
whole thing but that's something that is
within the bill for us to write the law
that the executive then executes so it
would be over on their side of the the
building that they uh conduct those sort
of
analyses thank you for taking my
followup could you give me an example of
something that you think would be a
subjective thing that's been approved
because I'm not clear on what you mean
by that sure um it's been my
understanding that especially when it
comes to some of the reading methods
that were popularized in the last maybe
20 30 years ago that there was an
emphasis placed not on objective score
metrics as far as can you read better
can we demonstrate that you read better
but we're legitimized through surveys
happening um in more recent times I
think there are portions of fields such
as trauma informed education social
emotional learning that Trend not
entirely but certainly in some cases
Trend toward subjective methods of
evaluation instead of the objective
metrics representative McDonald thank
you Mr chair and welcome back to
education representative am I correct in
saying that this would not prevent
students from being asked to take
surveys in school it simply just pre
prevents their surveys from being
presented as evidence-based when it's
self-reported data correct this this
doesn't have anything to do with a
Prohibition on on surveys or anything of
the kind great thanks
see no further questions thank you very
much
Banfield hit the
but uh my name is Amry Banfield I am a
parental rights Advocate focused on
excellence and
education today I come here in support
of
hb29 some of my background involves
tutoring elementary and middle school
children in mathematics I also had the
pleasure of participating in an online
Forum with mathematicians and Math
teachers from around the country for
those of you who remember the math Wars
about 15 years ago this for was set up
to promote quality math curriculum and
pedagogi in in
schools the mathematicians who
participated were some of the best and
brightest working at our top
universities needless to say I just kind
of watched and listened and asked
questions um they reviewed math
curriculum and pedagogia in detail and
identified the numerous problems within
some of the back then it was
textbooks the problems they pointed out
were exactly the problems I saw when I
was teaching kids math math if you're
going to expect kids to discover math
you better expect them to have to be
able to um access a tutor as kids don't
discover math today I'm in a I'm on a
forum with Math teachers from around the
country who gather to share ideas on
teaching math they talk about teaching
methods that have had a positive impact
on learning and share information about
some of the fattish teaching methods
that do not work well in the
classroom what I learned from teaching
children myself is that children need a
good quality math program and a good
teacher I do not subscribe to the idea
that kids can discover math on their own
while there may be a few outliers most
kids need direct instruction or their
parents will end up paying for a
tutor this idea that teachers should be
guides on the side marginalizes the
value of teachers in our
classroom too many teachers are
floundering and looking for Quality
information on teaching methods and
quality math programs
grateful that these teachers are
collaborating to find math programs and
teaching methods that will help them
fill the
gaps I think HB 129 is attempting to
identify good quality teaching methods
so teachers are not having to search for
this on their own I'm also going to
point to uh a position statement that I
have here by the El elth althia Society
the althia society is committed to
advocacy rooted in rigorous research SE
Arch and evidence they believe the most
effective advocacy is Guided by data and
insights that inform policy and practice
in special education and the related
fields so this is a position statement
in response to the nctm the National
Council of teachers of
mathematics so in the position so in
their position statement they're they're
replying to the um
nctm they say a position statement from
two national organizations the NC TM
teachers of mathematics and the C
Council for exceptional children focused
on the teaching of mathematics to all
students with disabilities is timely
given the strong research base in
special education about mathematics the
focus on c teacher preparation standards
about the use of research validated
practices and the focus in both General
and special education legislation about
the use of research validated practices
the expect is that such a position
statement would rely on a consensus of
current evidence in the field
unfortunately the nctm and the C
position statement falls short falls
falls well short of this expectation the
nctm and the C position statement
provided a list of actionable
recommendations for the mathematics
support of students with disabilities
however many of these recommendations
were merely beliefs and philosophy
without significant and rigorous
research to support them we expected
better from a position statement meant
to inform the crucial and complex
practice of providing mathematics
education for all students with
disabilities and thus call for position
statement that is grounded in now
considerable knowledge-based of
effective mathematics instructions for
students with
disabilities in 2021 The whatw Works
Clearing House produced a highquality
revieww in which some of the research on
assisting students who experience
difficulties with mathematics was
considered the wwc review resulted in
six recommendations with strong levels
of
evidence yet only one of these
recommendations in other words
mathematical representations was
mentioned in the nctm position statement
we would expect a position statement for
students with disabilities to focus on
all six recommendation including
representations mathematics vocabulary
number line computation fluency word
problem solving and system systemic
explicit instruction among the many
omissions from this position statement
is an emphasis on
systemic explicit instruction in the
high leverage practice documentation
from CEC the practice with the strongest
research base to support its use with
students with
disabilities it's not much longer but
I'm going to stop
here if you go to the American
Confederation of teachers website you're
going to find a a uh a study and it's
it's about um it's called putting
students on a path to learning and it is
a study that shows that guided
instruction is the best method of
teaching math in our
schools representative beler brought up
how some of these programs in our
schools dictate pedagogy he might not
have used that word but I will use it
they dictate pedagogy to the teachers
you open up a program and the program
says use inquiry based learning well
that's key that's code for get yourself
a
tutor and not all of these kids can
afford tutors not all of these parents
can go and hire tutors so what happens
is those kids fall through the cracks
when the teacher is not teaching but is
told is sometimes told yes sometimes
they are told you have to do it this way
and they're going to have to do it that
way unfortunately if that's what they're
being told
but my I I think the point of this is
let's narrow down what is evidence-based
what is research based so that at least
they're not floundering around trying to
figure out because this is what they've
been told works and then they're seeing
it in their own class that it's not
working so that's my um statement if you
have any questions I'm happy to to
provide them
um I I've just seen it personally I've
seen it personally this this idea of
this project based learning in math and
inquiry based learning um it
marginalizes the teacher in the
classroom and I don't understand it
because our teachers are professionals
they go to school to to to teach this
and then they're sidelined
sidelined and that doesn't help students
but it certainly helps tutors if that's
what if that's what you want to do thank
you any questions
yes Reb Paul you Mr chair and thank you
take my question so is this uh your idea
about not doing inquir based learning
and stuff is that for special needs only
that you're speaking about are you
speaking students absolutely not all
students and again you know I I I like
that there's an exception that the
teacher can divert from that if so be
because when you're talking about a
gifted student um they have that
capacity a lot of times they you know I
don't get the kids I didn't get the kids
who were gifted in math matter of fact
my son's gifted in math and guess what
he would do cuz they we my kids were in
a school back then that used this pedoi
all of his friends would call him at
night asking him to explain the math
that the teacher refused to teach now
this woman was an amazing woman this
teacher she was told use this
constructivism use this pedagogy in the
classroom and so he'd come home some of
the kids I was tutoring some of the kids
would call him and say can you explain
how this works
so a lot of times what happens is your
gifted kids can work their way through a
system like that they can figure it out
so in a class like that where you say
that you separate the kids maybe that's
something that those kids don't need as
as much as explicit instruction but even
still my son who is gifted in math would
still come home frustrated angry at a
teacher who is an amazing person but she
was told she had to do it this way so
the frustration and the Ang is aimed
towards the teacher parents are calling
the teacher why aren't you teaching my
kids why aren't you teaching them math
and so this is this is Manifest itself
so I'd get these kids I'd actually teach
them and I learn what it means to be a t
teacher at that point because when that
light bulb goes out and when that
self-esteem improves because somebody's
actually teaching them it's like it's
like um a foreign language do you just
figure out a foreign language so
sometimes you pretty much have to be
taught what the words mean and so um
what I what what I like about this and
yes I see it in the programs I analyze
math programs all the time and it's in
there it tells the teachers how to teach
it's in the grants I don't know if you
know this but sometimes when we when we
um get grants in the schools it's
dictating pedagogi in those grants that
takes away the autonomy from the teacher
so yeah I do want a teacher to be able
to you know maneuver at the same same
time thank you that Mak sense
sure thank you for taking my question
sure could you clarify again for me I've
got a little confused by the words
access a
tutor just I'm I'm missing I I know what
you're saying about a tutor but I'm not
completely understanding why a tutor
would be doing the job that I know I
always did um as far as using techniques
um accessing a tutor would mean that if
that a student is in that environment in
a classroom where they are using the
discovery constructivism inquiry method
Project based learning those kind of
those kind of situations where which is
teaching methods
pedagogi uh where they're not actually
learning or or they're not understanding
because maybe they're working with
groups of kids and they're not really
understanding how to work work through a
math concept then a lot of times then
that's how I would get students so it
was sometimes it's the curriculum
sometimes it's a teaching method
sometimes it's both help my child
because this is what's going on in the
classroom and the anger aim towards the
teachers and I'm always like don't
necessarily blame the teacher they
didn't pick the curriculum and a lot of
times they're told this is what they
have to do thank you uh representative
Damon thank you very short question what
is the name of the society that you were
quoting their position
statement the National Council teacher
of
mathematics um the althia society it's a
l t h EI I a and I'm going to give you a
copy of this so that you can look at it
and then at the same time I would also
go read this position statement you know
I'm going to email it to you because
it's got links in it also the position
by the nctm that they're criticizing
thank you representa Terry I'm sorry um
one second followup sorry thank you
thank you for sending that and would you
also include the link to the position
statement that you're responding to yes
absolutely absolutely repr Terry thank
you uh at one at at one point in your
testimony um in your your narrative I
believe that you mentioned that um there
were six recommendations that were made
by was it the National Council of Math
teachers to a higher governing body five
of which were either rejected or ignored
only one of which was
adopted can
you do you have any idea or do you
know uh why the other five were not
either responded to positively or
rejected and um what they they are and
how this bill would address um the
concerns of the ncmt that were ignored
or rejected by the har governing body I
I brought this as an example mainly as
an example of the difficulty Within
These societies within um the nctm
within a a society like this that that
represents the students with
disabilities um how will it impact this
this particular how will it impact the
bill um I think it's just an example of
why it's needed why we need to narrow
down the evidence base why I think it's
good for public schools to narrow it
down because at the same time you've got
you know you've got these situations
where for instance in Manchester if this
is what they're doing in a classroom
these kids may not have access to a
tutor so if you are uh now somebody in
Bedford they might be able to afford a
tutor but the point is is if we can
narrow down what actually works well in
pedagogi um and again that aft uh the
what's on the AFT American Federation of
teachers I'll send that too um it is a
study that shows that guided instruction
works best in the classroom and I I feel
like it's um it's very uh it I just have
a strong belief just sitting with kids
and looking at all of the documentation
and evidence
that this attempt to remove a teacher
from
instruction not completely not
completely um has really damaged it's
been going on the nctm has been highly
criticized by the mathematicians I
worked with 15 years ago I can send you
that information some of you may have
already read it because I've included
I've sent it to the to the commissioner
in the past so I'm happy to send you
that but yes the nctm has been a a major
problem in math education they came up
with the fuzzy math standards back 20
years ago and they were highly
criticized by these mathematicians
around the country so we were you and I
think that they had the evidence to
prove it if you look at the Tims test
we're 25th in in on International scores
this is what they would point to the
nctm that has been involved with math
education in this country so you're
asking me to say why why would they do
something like that why would they do
that now you're asking me to get into
their head and I don't think that I
could provide you a a honest answer I
could
guess I could guess I mean I to me I've
just I have I would I would never trust
them from from years ago when and I mean
these mathematicians were well I'll I'll
send you information on it thank you
follow up quickly please so so I I I
just want to be clear um you are not
aware of why the recommendations were
rejected leading to your frustration and
the frustration of other Educators who
hold views similar to or the same as as
yours
um so so does this bill would this bill
be helpful to you in attempting to move
in the direction of resolving that
frustration
and achieving the laudable objectives
which you are stating for us today I
believe it would I believe that there's
enough evidence out there to promote
good quality pedagogi in the schools I
think there's enough evidence out there
to promote good math programs in the
school but that's not what this bill is
doing so yes I do believe that that
would that would be I think the
criticism a lot of times nctm is all
about hands off teachers you know let
kids Discovery discover learning and so
what they're basically doing is saying
you're not including information good
information like maybe um what the afts
on their website to counter what their
position statement was what they put out
there and this has been going on for
decades with the
nctm thank you very much see no further
questions thank you very much for your
testimony and that will end the hearing
on hb29 and and I am going to turn the
gavel over to representative dry for the
right we're going to take a couple
minutes to get straightened out and move
around
just
e
all right we're going to open the
hearing for house concurrent resolution
six and I'm going to introduce the
sponsor Mike beler representative Mike
beler thank you madam chairwoman thank
you members of the committee I will do
my best this time around to not
triggered an earthquake with my
promises okay I suspect everyone here is
familiar at least in a basic way with
the foundational facts that uh regarding
the incident that precipitated this
resolution for those needing refresher
or more details there are two media
articles containing uh details that I
have passed around you can peruse that
at your
leisure first it is within the purview
of this body as the grand inquest of the
state to remove remove any office holder
in either state or Local
Government after all it is this state in
this state according to our Constitution
and judicial precedent localities have
no authorities not granted to them by
this legislative
body if we can create a position by
Statute as we have here we have
oversight of that
position second this is a resolution
calling for a removal for
cause that cause is severalfold
the actions taken represent politization
of the position and the adoption of a
protected class of
rules adopted not by this
body but by the locality and in
contravention of this
body the parents in question that were
impacted by the
incident were charged with
harassment by the superintendent in
question in this
position and severely punish in actions
were taken based off of that
charge I have included with the handouts
harassment I've been cut off I won't
read the whole law please do peruse it
you will find that the allegations made
against the parents in question for the
behavior in question meets
none of the items outlined in New
Hampshire RSA
harassment
rather the rules adopted by a locality
meant to govern students on school time
minor
children were applied to adult citizens
of this state in trying to speak freely
action it is not reasonable to apply
such rules to an adult in New Hampshire
citizens who have the absolute right
within reasonable application of time
place and manner restrictions to protest
their government and speak
freely under no no circumstances can
text on an article of clothing that is
not obscene or
vulgar be barred under time place and
manner
restrictions time place and manner
restrictions are designed to
prevent people from um stopping
proceedings or interfering unnecessarily
in proceedings quiet protests can never
further the punishments inflicted
including a total prohibition of parents
stepping foot on school grounds for any
reason is an outlandish punishment that
ought to be reserved only for legitimate
threats and ought to include due process
of law for deprivation of a liberty
interest on on the part of that
parent the prohibition rendered so far
exceeded both the authority of the
position of superintendent and the
punishments themselves so far exceeded
any reasonable application in the
circumstances that this cannot be viewed
as anything other than politically
motivated a move meant to inflict a
chilling of speech generally on New
Hampshire
citizens there is substantial historical
precedent for the use of such a
resolution in this
state going back as early as the early
19th
century we have not just a power but an
affirmative duty to act where citizens
are deprived of their rights by a person
holding an office created by this body
thank you I would be happy to take
question thank you uh yes I'm going to
as representative Hall thank you madam
chair and and thank you representative
for taking my question I'm just curious
U given that this is in the courts right
now um given that it targets a specific
individual did you get any push back at
Os or in the speaker's office with this
legislation
or thank you for the question there was
push back isn't the right word there was
some
um understanding difficulties in
crafting this bill under what section of
law in the Constitution this was falling
under because this is not merely a
concurrent resolution that is the manner
in which it is drafted but
constitutionally this falls under a bill
of
address representative sik thank you
very much and thank you for taking my
question um I'm trying to understand
where your motivation comes from given
that you don't live in this District you
don't um as far as I understand have
children in this school district you're
not part of this District you're from a
Community 45 miles away and what uh what
would make this relevant to to you given
that it's not something wouldn't it be
an issue for local control and for the
local community to take their own
personal stance about their support of
their superintendent thank you for the
question absolutely not we cannot sit by
as Representatives at the state level of
government while the rights of citizens
anywhere in the state are trampled by
local government it is within our
purview to oversee local government and
as I said as a Dylan's rule state local
government only has the authority
granted them by this body otherwise they
exist representative
NATO thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so reading all of
this and I've heard a little bit more
about it but
um this uh parent is obviously concerned
for his daughter's better welfare as B
in point of the Olympics and the boxing
competition uh I kind of agree with that
they're not saying uh you can't play
sports just that there is a point in
time where the physical ability is a
quite different uh as far as strength
and ability uh and one of the point of
order I I don't think that's what this
bill is about and I think it's point of
order that that it's it's a different
discussion for a different bill I I
don't think that's what we're here to
talk about could you phrase a question
that directly addresses the
topic okay so you think his uh freedom
of
speech would be relevant
here thank you for the question yes I do
I think I think a host of uh freedoms
covered under the First Amendment to the
Federal Constitution as well as the New
Hampshire con tion are implicated here
including freedoms of speech and
Association and of the right to petition
one's government yes thank you
representative
Woodcock thank you madam chair um good
to see you again twice in one day
um I want to move away from the issue
the the topical issue that caused this
uh concern but more to the hiring firing
practice of a local school committee I
would think that having been in
education in schools for Way beond Way
Beyond three decades that those
authorities lay a lie with the local
school board to hire or fire
superintendent or assistant
superintendent or business manager then
of course a recommendation
superintendent on the way down so I
don't understand honestly why we would I
understand your concern about people's
rights in your position I understand I'm
not suting it's not legal I'm suggesting
that the school board has an authority
to make a determin if they want to hire
a person fire a person under the
Collective bodying Agreement and if it's
an individual contract the
superintendent that's their sole right
to do that so I don't know why we would
want to oversee or override the the
provisions of the local school board
dealing with the local uh in this case
superintendent forgetting the issue
specifically but rather the the idea
thank you thank you for the question I
think it's a perfectly Fair argument to
suggest that one would rather see such a
decision left to the local school board
however from a process standpoint we
have the authority to look at this issue
because any person anywhere in the state
who believes their rights are being
deprived by a local body has the right
to appeal to a higher body of government
for
redress that's what's happened here
we're looking to a higher body at the
state level to redress what wasn't
handled at the local level and there is
great historical precedent for this in
the 18th century sorry 19th century uh
mid 19th century a County coroner was
process
follow 1800 corer as we talking big
this I understand the the piece but um I
guess the falling up the same
piece we're not trying to
redress the decision by the
superintendent nor the right of the
parents to do what they think is right I
have no issue with that what I have the
issue with is that we're trying to tell
the local school board how to deal with
their superintendent that's not an our
issue we have the do we have the legal
right absolutely should we putting our
feet in that water absolutely
not my opinion thank you I don't think
there was a question I appreciate the
opinion representative
Damon thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my
question would you
comment on what kind of precedent if
this resolution were to pass this
sets in including in your response
relative to as you cited Dylan's
rule I am very concerned that this sets
a precedent that state government could
be involved in the hiring and firing of
any
local locally hired person for any
position whatsoever if there's a
grievance thank you I am very hopeful to
say exactly such a precedent that we
might step in to directly remove holders
of office from any position in the state
where they have deprived citizens of
their
Liberties do you also incorporate in
your now stated objection to remove
holders of
office all kinds of employees I was
actually I appreciate that information
but that's not what I was asking I was
asking about hired individuals Not
Elected
individuals thank you and to make that
distinction clear there's only under the
government there's only two types of
persons there's elected and there's
appointed to office all office holders
including employees are office holders
government follow up go
ahead I don't think I got the answer to
the question thank you for the
clarification on the
terminology but I'm trying to understand
what you expect as precedent
for every
employee however you uh Define them of a
school district of a municipality so if
I don't like the care of the roads in my
town and to be clear I think my town
roads are very well cared for
um then can I petition to have the state
remove my road
agent absolutely people can petition for
anything and by right of our
constitution we have the authority to do
but it would have to meet the necessary
threshold in both this body and in the
happen representative
Freeman thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for coming in front
of us I think it's very important that
people understand that we all have
rights um can you cite referencer in
your research have you found any other
instances of the state getting involved
in Schoolboard matters at this
level thank you for your question I'm
not aware of any uh direct involvement
in removal of a school hired Personnel
in the school board but the school board
exists under the same uh rubric of
government as a County government or a
local government does it's under the
state so
only there would be no legal or
constitutional issue as far as pursuing
somebody within any um aspect of state
or local government under a under a bill
of address by the New Hampshire
Constitution has has been done
repeatedly in this state thank you
further
questions thank you very much thank you
yes since the sponsors had all the time
that he needs to explain this we have a
long list of people lined up could you
please hold your testimony to two to
three
minutes mam chair I'd be happy to thank
you good
morning Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Jerry FW the
associate executive director of the New
Hampshire school administrators
Association I come before you that to
this hearing to ask that you deem a HCR
6 as inexpedient to legislate and here's
why it's not this body's responsibility
to adjudicate free speech that belongs
in another branch of government the
hiring and firing of a local school
superintendent is the responsibility of
the local school board not the
legislature this body doesn't
necessarily know the facts or that are
surrounding that incident being debated
nor is it necessarily familiar with the
law local school board's
policy whose enforcement responsibility
is the
superintendent judgments and decisions
needed to be made at at that time based
on the school district policy and
ultimately with the obligation to
provide a safe environment for students
and others gathered at a school event
the end of the day this resolution
exceeds the responsibility of this body
erodes the duties and resp
responsibilities of a local school
district and makes assumptions based on
a lack of knowledge of The Facts of the
matter we ask that the wisdom of this
committee Prevail and determine this
bill as an expedient to legislate thank
you questions representative Cel thank
you um representative belter made the
statement that he thought the state
should have the authority to override a
school district or other local
government elected bodies hiring and
firing decisions do you agree that
that's an
appropriate action thank you for the
question representative Su I claim not
to be a constitutional uh specialist and
uh would not be uh comfortable offering
an opinion on
that representative mois thank you madam
chair um so if the local school board
does not act on an
unconstitutional action of a
superintendent if not us then who is
there to protect the parents and
students
thank you for the question
representative Mor I believe that a
local school district local school board
does have the authority and will make
the appropriate decisions based on their
knowledge of the matter and the
situation at hand I do believe that
items of free speech are adjudicated in
another branch of this government and in
fact May well be the
case further questions seeing none thank
you very much thank you madam
chair like to call
Clement
Madden thank
you thank you for having me Madam chair
and greetings to the members of the
committee and I appreciate the
opportunity to speak on hr6 calling for
the removal of the superintendent of
school administrative unit
67 could you introduce yourself please
my name is Clement Madden and I am the
dun Barton School Board chair and a
member of the sau67 board as well dun
Barton is one of the two districts in
sau67 the other being Bo of
course I'm here today to express my
confusion Regarding why anyone in the
New Hampshire State Legislature thinks
that they have any right to terminate a
lawfully executed contract between the
elected officials that comprise the seu
67 board and their administrative
leaders including our superintendent
Marcy
Kelly RSA 194c col 5 Roman 3 states
impertinent part that quote the school
administrative unit board shall have the
authority to remove superintendent and
other administrators end quote this law
does not state that the board's
Authority is subject to the legislature
under any circumstances simply put the
legislature has no Authority
here I think this bill attempts to
engage in an issue that is currently
before a judge and Federal Court
specifically in a manner that has no
meaningful impact on the process and
appears to only be meant to grab
headlines or otherwise try to whip up
some sort of political rhetoric for
benefit more so the wording of the be
Bill appears to lack any understanding
of the issues and nuances surrounding
the multiple incidents that occurred on
the sidelines of the bo High School
varsity girls soccer team games this
past fall we do not need to get into
those as this is not the court where
that issue is being decided which leads
me to wonder why anyone let alone a
representative from Wakefield thinks
that they can inject themselves into a
matter where they have no jurisdiction
in a town where they don't live and do
so in a manner that tries to preempt a
federal court ruling that hasn't been
made yet I think this bill is ridiculous
and I urge the committee to decline to
forward I would also add that
superintendent Kelly is a full support
of the Dumbarton School Board there is
much more to the job of superintendent
than having to deal with grandstanding
individuals who appear to be attempting
to get likes or otherwise trying to
motivate a specific group of people by
targeting a 14-year-old student our
superintendent does a great job in all
areas of her portfolio of
responsibilities and in the specific
issue this resolution is attempting to
highlight she was dealing with a
singular unprecedented and novel protest
apparently designed to create headlines
during that process she was working with
Council in a manner meant to abide by
all the laws regulations and policy IES
that are in effect from the federal
government the state of New Hampshire
the New Hampshire inter Scholastic
Athletic Association sa67 in the B
school district superintendent Kelly
should be commended for her actions and
not subject to some clickbait resolution
questions representative McDonald thank
you madam chair and thank you for your
testimony I imagine um the
superintendent Marcy Kelly is aware of
this resolution has the dunard and
School Board spoken to her at all about
this is she aware of this yeah she's
you uh representative Woodcock thank you
m chair just a good morning s thank you
for coming down just a point of
clarification I I
um in respect to representativ vela's
putting this bill before us as ACR now
it's not often at all that I agree with
representative Bela
BR but I do think he has the right to do
that um and I would say in my last two
years of working with him here he
consistently brings bills that question
the Constitution how they interpret it
so I'm not suggesting this bill is good
I just I want to be clear that I don't I
don't think his motivation was for his
own personal gain that's
all may I respond to that or not he
asked you the question I would suggest
that since this is a federal court right
now being de decided as a civil issue
there really is no point to him trying
to presume a ruling that hasn't been
made yet which is what his bill does
unconstitutional I would agree with that
but that that was my attempt but thank
you representative Cel thank you so much
and thank you and thank you so much for
taking my question I want to ask you the
same question I asked the representative
from the school boards Association do
you believe that the state legislature
has the right to overturn the decision
of an elected body within another
section of the state in my opinion and
from what the RSA that I read said no
they do not Mas quick followup yes
followup thank you so much and if the
voters in that District were unsatisfied
with the decision do they have recourse
yes they do have recourse of course
there's always elections for school
board officials and also if they are
unhappy with a school board decision
they can go to the State Board of
Education which is is how this works
thank you any other questions
representative
Damon this isn't actually a question I
just want to thank you and all of the
other school board members for your
active engagement with public schools in
these challenging
times thank you I appreciate that any
other questions thank you very much for
coming thank you I'd like to call Bryce
laraby
my ears are burning a little bit since
I'm the both School Board Bryce larby
I've been the longtime chair of the the
school district and
um it's had a big impact on our on our
district and obviously Mrs Kelly as well
uh I'm here to speak on behalf of the
entire board um even though I'm I'm the
only one speaking on their behalf we are
in all are in agreement and we
strenuously object to this bill we
support M Kelly in all of her actions
and let me explain a little bit about
that the school board has really two
fundamental jobs it's creating budgeting
and finance and creating policies the
administration is the ones that
administer those policies it's our
policies that they administer and it's
at our direction that they do what they
do and we are still consistently happy
and pleased with what Miss Kelly has
done and she does our most fundamental
policy it's the protection of kids it's
the safety of kids and it doesn't matter
what the issue is our view is we're
there to protect those
children now September 17th is the the
date when this incident happened the
school knew a week beforehand that there
were people with plans to do something
disrupt that event in some way shape or
form targeted at an individual the
school looked into this those
individuals even reached out to the
school both meetings and emails the
school knew something was going to
happen and Miss Kelly took the action
appropriately she perceived something
was going to happen that was going to
make a child
uncomfortable and we put an end to that
we don't know what could have happened
more if the school hadn't stepped in
maybe there are even even greater plans
we we don't know but this was a highly
unusual event I've coached over a
thousand games myself my estimate is
I've been to 4,000 on top of that my son
recently tried out for the Chicago Bears
like I know Sports and in those 5,000
games I've never once been seen a
protest and more importantly I've never
seen parents want to take the spotlight
away from their child who's
participating so this is an
unprecedented situation that M Kelly was
presented with and she acted accordingly
and it had nothing to do with
transgender rights if parents were there
to make fun of somebody because of their
last name or their hair color or their
shoes we expect the school to do the
same thing we expect them to step in and
not allow any sort of harassment to
children and even if that harassment
doesn't happen if they're perceiving
that something like that's going to
happen we expect them to step in and do
that and we applaud what Miss Kelly and
the administration did and minutes if
we're wrong on what we approach that we
don't want to be right we we are there
fundamentally about protecting the
children thank you
questions representative
Hall thank you madam chairman thank you
for taking my question are you aware of
the support that the bow um has received
on the online testimony I don't know if
you've seen any of the testimony on how
positive it is you know hundreds of
people have you know 90% have said that
they um oppose this this resolution
actually I am not okay well it's there
read it's very interesting thank you any
other questions seeing none thank you
very much thank you I'd like to call
Marcy
Kelly good morning Madame chair and um
members of this committee thank you for
the opportunity uh to provide testimony
this morning my name is Marcy Kelly I'm
a resident of sanon New Hampshire as
well as a proud product of New Hampshire
Public Schools professionally I serve as
superintendent of schools for SAU 67
serving the communities of B and
Dunbarton it won't surprise you to know
that I'm here today to voice my strong
opposition the house concurrent
resolution six introduced by
representative beler which calls for my
removal as
superintendent this resolution
represents a significant overreach by
the state legislature imposing is a
serious threat to the foundational
principle of local control that is long
defined New Hampshire's governance and
education
systems New Hampshire has a rich
tradition of empowering local
communities to manage their schools hgr
6 undermines this tradition by allowing
political interference to replace the
thoughtful localized decision-making
that best serves our students in
communities leadership decisions within
our schools was must remain the
responsibility of locally elected school
boards who are directly accountable to
their constituents not dictated by
political pressures at the state
level as superintendent my primary
responsibility is to create a safe
respectful and supportive environment
for every student and staff member
schools should be places where learning
and personal growth are prioritized free
from political agendas or
sensationalized media
narratives my role requires careful and
sometimes diff ult decision-making that
is grounded In fairness professionalism
and the best interests of the entire
School Community while adhering to the
law public education must remain a safe
stable and a political space where
students are given the tools to learn
and grow HCR 6 by seeking to remove me
for political reasons sets a dangerous
precedent that jeopardizes school
leadership and exposes it to the
shifting whims of politics rather than
focusing on the needs of students and
sta
I urge you to reject HCR 6 and to
reaffirm New Hampshire's commitment to
local control by doing so you'll help
preserve the trust and autonomy that
Empower communities to make decisions in
the best interest of their schools and
students thank you for your time and
thoughtful consideration I remain
dedicated to supporting our schools our
staff and most importantly our students
thank you any
questions representative woodcock thank
you chairman super thank you for coming
and and I appreciate your your comments
um I don't have to have a question I
just want to thank you for being a
superintendent of schools and feel badly
for the difficulty you have had to go
through in protecting kids thank you
thank you representative
any other questions see none thank
you for your time than
three Mike
mik man de Cason ex superintendent of
school c67 now happily retired Marc made
the absolute right decision she did not
violate these people's constitutional
rights the controlling Supreme Court Cas
is the Tinker case which every
Administration administrator learns has
to do with wearing black Iron bands
during the Vietnam war there were
students who warn who wore them they
were suspended from school for
expressing the political view students
have a right to express their political
views in school and that right should
not be curtailed these were not students
expressing their political view these
were parents who were guests at a high
School sports game that is a limited
public forum it is not a street corner
where your first amendment
constitutional rights of free speech are
unregulated superintendent has the right
to regulate time space and Manner and if
they are going to restrict speech it has
to do on the element of
disruption if a child brings a
Confederate flag onto the school grounds
they may be suspended from school they
may not depending on the case for
disruption you bring that into a black
high school suspend from school because
you're going to call it disruption you
bring it into a white high school like
Bo was we'll probably have a
conversation with you about the relative
for disruption everything I saw about
this incident it was designed to be
disruptive Marcy was not only in her
rights to suspend those students from
school it was her responsibility to now
let's talk about nhiaa nhiaa controls
Sports in the state we have been looking
at this transgender issue for over a
decade it is complex it's not simple
yeah Connecticut the state holders in
the 100 yard Des are transgender females
unfair Advantage 120 lb soft more
playing on a soccer team you tell me
what the issue is there except for you
just don't like the fact that she's
transgender you tell
me all this other stuff goes away Marcy
was
protecting a student who needed to be
protected one of the things about nhiaa
is you do not single a player out on the
other team
shooting a foul shot you shouldn't be
talking about that person's mother
saying their their name or anything it's
part of
sportsmanship these people were in the
stands they are guests of the school
district yes they're
parents but they don't have an unlimited
right to come in and do whatever they
want it's a limited public form and the
courts have traditionally recognized
that superintendent and school
administrators need that to go forward
and the last thing I'll say actually two
last things one this body passed a that
said we're going to prevent bullying in
schools that's what Marcy was doing
there was a power differential of adults
organized against a single student on
another team that's bullying and she
stood up and said no we're not going to
let that happen this body passed the law
and asked us to do this and final does
this body own
superintendence he used to the
commissioner education used to sign our
our our contracts now it's all local
control 3 minutes three minutes I have
three left oh man I'm want a roll all
right you want control pay for
it you pay like a poultry $55,000 per
students the rest of it comes up here no
no it goes to control it goes to who has
the right to hire and fire time five
minutes
no I'm done you're done thank you very
much good to see you too M good to see
you the rest of you I may not
know uh okay representative Cel and then
representative Freeman thank you so much
and thank you for taking my question and
also for having served as a
superintendent and working with
nhiaa which I'm very familiar as a
parent of an athlete um I'm curious what
you were speaking at the end about who
has ultimate control over the
superintendent so if I'm unhappy with my
school superintendent could you tell me
from your perspective what's my recourse
about how to address that you go and
talk to your school board and I have had
with a couple gentlemen that already
spoke here today some uncomfortable
conversations with them about my
behavior and what they did and what I
was representing and if you don't like
that you go and you vote your school
board out you get a new school board in
there and get you but it's a contract
between the local school board with
mostly local funds playing for it and
the person who works for them that's
what it is I mean I I don't see where
the state as a legislature has the right
to go and and mess with that
especially when you don't fund that much
thank representative Freeman
Madam chair I defer I I have my question
answered thank you any other
questions thank you for your time thank
you so much it's always fun coming down
Osborne I think this was left on I'm
Adam osbor um I'm a principal in BO I'm
an administrator in BO and I promise to
be brief I'll try not to go back
overground that others have covered but
I do want to U touch on two points today
in the first I was going to talk a
little bit more at length around the
different levels of governance you know
local County State and then Federal um
because I think that's fundamentally why
this is a dangerous situation I think
that I recognize that people from out of
the bow in Dunbarton locality may be
displeased with the way things played
out the people with in within Bo D Bon
are pleased and I think that's because
it speaks to Marcy's character but
that's my second point I'll come back to
that in a moment I think the danger is
I'd like to offer an illustration to
better kind of encapsulate this would be
what if it were the federal government
looking down on employees of the state
questioning who we had as a department
head or a commissioner of and you can
fill in the blank for which agency state
agency want I think we'd be IRA I think
the members around this table would be
irate because it wouldn't be within the
scope of their Authority it wouldn't be
within the lane that we generally
ascribe to that level of governance and
they should stay out of that but by the
same token I think the state should stay
out of this this is an issue of local
control and that's a Bedrock principle
of public schooling in New Hampshire we
value that and it's important the second
point I want to come to is is really the
question and I I think I'm uniquely
positioned kind of two talk to this
because Marcy's my boss I love working
for Marcy but the reason we're here
today is part of the reason I love
working for Marcy Mrs Kelly is a person
of conviction and character and the
whole reason we're talking here today is
because she believes she was doing the
right thing standing up for kids as an
educational administrator as a person
who's worked in schools for 30
years that's a core value and if we're
ever going to air or not air
well air let it be on the side of
Defending kids as as Mr larby said if
it's wrong then we don't want to be
right and and I agree with him so I I'll
stop my comments there but I think it's
an issue of local control staying within
our respective governance lanes and then
I appreciate and applaud Mrs Kelly for
her conviction and character and
strength of character standing up for
children thank you any questions
representative Damon thanks Madam chair
thank you for taking my
question it's really a question for most
who have spoken would you comment about
the value to students
of the way this process was handled and
the respect for their
safety I think that that's a really good
question with a complex set of answers
and just to be clear I am the Middle
School principal not the high school
principal so I was not Frontline to the
varsity girls soccer game where this
occurred so all I can do is kind of
Imagine just as you would um but I think
our I have amazing respect for kids
period students are are brilliant smart
capable young people um and I think what
they witnessed that day was a thoughtful
response by Matt F the high school
principal Mike desit the High School
athletic director and also Mrs Kelly the
superintendent as they tried to
construct a safe and positive
environment for those two soccer teams
to come together and play they tried to
be clear with what the expectations were
prior to that game beyond that I don't
think I'm really too qualified to speak
to the answer just because I wasn't
there and it's not my school building
but they were
thoughtful other
questions s oh representative Terry
thank you sir
um I I've been hearing folks who've been
testifying um speaking about the Primacy
the role in the Primacy of local control
mhm um and and I would like to just
refer to or or build off of a comment
made by representative Woodcock with
respect to our
knowledge uh of Representative belger
and the particular concerns that that he
has for the protection of constitutional
rights and and as I'm reading the the
resolution it appears to me that
representative beler is effectively
disagreeing with um the uh the local uh
school board with respect to certain
constitutionally protected
rights sir would it be your view then
that if the if if individuals were
dissatisfied with the way in which the
local school board adjudicated
um this
situation that the appropriate recourse
would they have any recourse beyond the
local school board and if so and if it
might be the federal Judiciary or the
state Judiciary the judicial branch
would it be the Judiciary and not the
general court in your
view I'm I'm not a lawyer or a legal
expert but I think Mr Madden did a
really good job of kind of addressing
that um when he talked about it being in
a a court process already and I think it
would be premature for this body to
assume to supersede and step in over
what the school board has done so far
because I I think if I understand your
question correctly it's there's a legal
pending case already in
process oh so just to be 100% crystal
clear here that if if Folks at the local
level are dissatisfied with the way in
which
would be that that this has been handled
that their their appropriate recourse
would be the Judiciary where I
understand this this matter currently
lies I I think two things and I hope I'm
not misunderstanding your question um I
think if you're asking about local
citizens of bow and Dunbarton they would
go through the bow and dartan school
boards I think someone had referenced
the state's Board of Education beyond
that I think uh I was probably
misunderstood understanding your
question initially okay thank you any
other
questions seeing none thank you very
Co okay good morning thank you to the
committee um I'm Jacqueline Co and in
full transparency I am a colleague of
Marc's uh superintendent in a
neighboring town but I come here today
as a resident of bo uh urging you to
find the resolution in expediated to
legislate um as a Bo resident I vote for
a school board and their jobs are to set
policy establish a budget and hire and
fire the superintendent so echoing what
has been said in the testimonies today
um you know I find this a gross attempt
to usurp local control and uh I am in
full support of superintendent Kelly and
the school
board and their actions to protect
children thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much um Robert last name starts with an
handwriting Malay thank you very much
thank you uh Madam chair thank you
members of the committee for allowing me
to speak on this um proposed resolution
which I encourage you to um kill that
proposed resolution as quickly as it was
offered to you I'm sorry could you just
introduce yourself sure my name is
Robert Malay I am a resident of keen New
Hampshire um born and raised in BO New
Hampshire spent a lot of time there
before they even had a high school
before they even had an elementary
school went to conquer High School where
Christen mcalli was one of our teachers
and I was there at the time of that
unfortunate tragedy as well um I am the
superintendent outon Kean I am coming as
a colleague of Marcy's to encourage you
to kill this bill or this proposed
resolution for all of the reasons that
you've heard I'm not going to reiterate
anything that has already been said but
I also sit as a member of the nhiaa
council um appointed by the nhsaa to
that body and Dr cascaden had already
shared with you that we've
been looking at this issue for a decade
um and he's not wrong and what Marcy did
was what all superintendant what all
administrators and throughout all of our
schools is charged to do and that's to
protect children whether they are
students in our district or they are
visiting for a sporting event we're
talking about a 14-year-old kid who was
there to play a soccer game um as a
superintendent out in Kean there have
been number numerous times where we have
gone to our student body who had
prepared signage of some sort to gain
some sort of a a psychological advantage
over visiting team members and we have
taken them and we have escorted students
away from that contest because it's just
not okay it's just not okay to do that
to young people who are there to perform
to um participate in a sport that they
enjoy and should be free of any type of
retaliation whether it be from students
or from adults and so
with your with your um hard work that's
in front of you I hope that you would
consider killing this proposed
resolution as quickly as it came to you
and I'm happy to answer any questions
you might have any
questions seeing none thank you very
much my name is is Judith goodno I'm a
resident of bo uh for over 20 years um
I'm not going to repeat everything that
people said I signed up early because I
didn't see the crowd until uh a few
minutes before um you opened the hearing
um but the only thing that I would add
in addition to the contractual uh
interference and uh support that we have
for uh Marcy um is that uh this doesn't
have a fiscal note and it would require
the um School Board to spend money to
find a new superintendent uh should that
happen um so that just as a practical
note but um as a resident of B I can
tell you that we fully support uh
Marcy thank you thank you any questions
sitting done thank you very much and
hello my name is Michael betet I'm here
as a resident of the town of B not as uh
my professional capacity although I do
uh for full disclosure work as an
assistant superintendent in a
neighboring School District um I won't
Echo anything else that other people
have said about the wonderful qualities
uh that Marcy uh brings forward to the
superintendency superintendency she is a
wonderful superintendent by all counts I
do want to remind however the committee
about the importance of following
constitutional law so if we're going to
have a discussion today about Free
Speech rights and about the rights of
our parents to come onto our school
campuses what I would ask us to do is
also remember that it's important to
think about due process Clauses within
the Constitution under the fifth and the
14th
Amendment right now as we're sitting
back the fifth amendment guarantees that
no person shall be deprived of their
life liberty or property without the due
process of law currently uh
superintendent Kelly is in a court case
that's unsettled it's a federal court
case it's undetermined and yet
representative uh who's moved this
forward seems to feel it's appropriate
to publicly shame and humiliate Marcy
Kelly's Body of work and the decisions
that she's made when she has not been
proven guilty in the court of law in any
way shape or form secondly the 14th
Amendment extends the guarantee to the
states the Clause ensures individuals
are treated fairly by the justice system
not by the legislative body by the
justice system and lastly the sixth
amendment guarantees the right to a fair
trial including the right to confront
Witnesses the right to a public trial
the right to impartial juries this
framework supports the idea the burden
of proof lies with the prosecution not
public sentiment so I ask you to think
very carefully about your balancing of
your equation when you want to look at
one Clause under the Constitution but
willfully ignore many many others thank
you question representative mcdonell
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here you appear to know quite a
bit about constitutional law so my
question is kind of along those lines I
if this HCR were to pass since it is a
resolution as opposed to a bill is there
some teeth to this is the school board
forced to comply with this so I'm going
to answer your question I am no more an
expert than you are because I'm I uh
graduated from a high school a public
school that taught civics and I'm
actually wonderfully uh glad for that
experience to have that opportunity to
know a little bit about what
constitutional law is all about that's
the limitation that I would turn that
over to lawyers who know better than I
but I will say this that as a resident
of Bo as a town of B when not if I
suspect that the board was um tasked by
the state to to move on this particular
action if that was to be the case I
would be happy to see a small increase
in my taxes which are already very high
for the funding of the lawsuit against
the state for the overreach on on their
ability to try to do what it is that
they think that they're able to do all
right thank you representative Cel thank
you so much and thank you for taking my
question I'm
curious if the state were to pass this
legislation um or this this resolution
sorry to be to make sure I'm being
precise with my language what do you
think do you think it would have a
chilling effect on the ability of school
boards to be able to hire
and continue to employ superintendents
in a state where we already have a
significant shortage of superintendent
candidates I think it's reasonable to
assume that there are boards who would
feel that way um many boards however
might feel just the opposite I think
that would have to be be the a function
of the community and the board that
represents it um I will say this the
power and I've spoken to this many many
times the power of local control and the
ability to vote in elected members of
the represent representative communities
um is a powerful one it's not one that
we want to throw away it's not one that
we want to ignore the job of a
superintendent is not it is not you'll
hear me say it it is absolutely not to
determine what the what the issues of
the community um are under the law in
terms of how and and why politically we
perceive them we act on the on the on
the board when the board drives us we
advise them we support them we follow
the laws that we can but we work with
our Council we work with our board to
enact what it is that we're charging to
do to make sure that we that we
administer the policies of the school
district and that's all Marcy did she
worked within the boundaries of her role
follow up if you can do it quickly thank
you so much for allowing me a followup
and if as we're in your role as an
assistant superintendent if you believe
your school board directed you to do
something that you believed was illegal
would you have recourse absolutely we
would um any superintendent who had
questioned about what they were doing um
was illegal under the law would first of
all they would represent through Legal C
Council whatever that perspective is um
they would bring legal counsel to bear
on the board the board would hear those
conversations in non-public setting they
would have maybe public setting they
would have those conversations and then
they would have the opportunity to
direct the superintendent to take action
in accordance with what they believe was
the appropriate action thank you so any
other questions seeing none I'm going to
six nine whatever
six
nobody
e
we're going to start the next Hearing in
one
minute
person on this side just went to the
bathroom cuz she thought we were on
this
I'm going to call the hearing for House
Bill 208 fiscal
note to order and recognize
I I think it's still good morning barely
um I I'm representative Jess Edwards I
represent the towns of uh Auburn Candia
Chester and Deerfield it's Rockingham
District 31 um I'm here today to
introduce House Bill 208 with a fiscal
note um what
208 the the way 208 was born uh it it
was a you know before Bill submission I
try to make a habit of going to a school
board meeting and asking them what I
could do to help them and uh the school
board uh in a public hearing asked me to
do support four bills uh I negotiated it
down to three um the other one wanted a
bunch of money
retroactively um uh but this one seemed
to be reasonable they are having trouble
hiring School nurses under the existing
law um and the principal um Lori Collins
um thought that um if if we could take
another look at the requirements for the
position it may be possible to uh make
it a little more flexible for hiring to
take place without violating the
critical need to maintain quality of
care and so uh listening to her I
drafted something up and then I talked
to my good friend over in the school
nurse Association I I I think you might
hear from them and uh I believe we've
found a mutual mutually accommodative
position where we can make the law a
little bit more flexible and and keep it
within the Professional Standards of our
School nurses so if you look at line two
it basically says uh it adds that um in
their in their uhr current experience
that they could have acute or chronic
care
experience uh it changes the requirement
around pediatric nursing into showing a
a priority within pediatric settings um
it uh creates an
Andor um around the uh skill sets so
that people of varying backgrounds might
become eligible for consideration uh of
course the hiring you'd still want to
hire the best available but if you can't
hire anyone you have no quality you have
no school nurse and and that's what um
uh at least the Auburn Village School
was confronting is they they don't have
one because they can't hire one and so
um so the other online um seven is is
another tweak to to talk about aptitude
in other words you know if we if we find
a u a less experience I.E maybe younger
um nurse that um has great potential and
a great passion for this line that uh
they they they ought to have an
opportunity to compete and and hopefully
have a merit-based system to reward the
the best qualified so so that's what
hp28 does it's why I'm introducing it
I'll take any questions any
questions restive
Freeman thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for bringing forward
this bill
um this from what I understand you're
saying this would allow districts to
have more flexibility around hiring I.E
experience and starting pay is that
correct I I I had a hard time hearing
whether you said inexperienced or
experienced thank you representative I
wouldn't say inexperience I'd say
experience so this would allow the
districts to have more flexibility
around experience and or starting pay is
that correct I I I'm trying to be too
precise I think I I think what the
flexibility does is it uh trades off
some of the harder uh positions around
stated experience to uh to allow for
aptitude and potential uh so so in that
way in that regard I think it's meant to
be more flexible thank you
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question are they
having a hard time hiring people because
of these reasons or because School
nurses now have to be certified by the
Department of Education and have two
certifications one nursing and one with
the Board of Education I I had really
asked I pleaded actually uh with the
principal to show up and explain the
problems she's had with the hiring
system I I know that in the public
comments during the school board uh she
she went into length about how um um she
she would present someone that she
thought was a good applicant and had
trouble at the board of education level
getting sort of their approval now I
have to disclaim all of this I I I this
is not my subject matter uh she told me
this in a meeting in August or something
I've had a lot of fun since then so I
don't know exactly what she said to me
but I think her comment was that it the
the challenge was getting an applicant
past the Board of
Education uh criteria thank you and I I
showed her this language there's follow
up on that I've showed her this language
and she thinks this language would help
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my
question it's not entirely clear to me
and perhaps you can help me better
understand this although it may be more
for the nursing
people um in line two and line three I
don't really see the proposed new
language as changing the
qualifications because the original
language says current experience in
pediatric nursing or other related
nursing areas so how is changing it to a
priority in pediatric settings
it I I just don't see how it changes
anything um I uh I drafted this in in
August submitted it to a few reviews um
I this this ended up kind of in my my
voice probably and uh I I just wanted to
clarify that uh regardless of the other
related nursing areas there was still a
priority on Pediatric we weren't dumping
pediatric we were just putting it in the
context of it's it being a priority not
a a requirement that we keep someone
from being
compliant I appreciate the intent okay
uh representative Woodcock thank
you represent
um I appreciate the fact you're bringing
something to help this I just want to
Clarity on your response to
representative Cornell when you were
talking just said the Board of Education
criteria were you talking about the
local school board or the Department of
Education license shff criteria I I
think I meant to be referring to the
Department of Education criteria yeah
they the the school okay was happy with
the applicant and was not allowed to
proceed with hiring I think may follow
follow up thank you um just two quick
other ones I heard you refer to the scho
school Nurses Association is there SP
person here okay I want to ask you that
one um finally one thank you um short
how thank you how you determine what do
you mean by acute acute care AC acute
care it's a it it's a word in healthc
care acute is kind of an emergent injury
based sort of care like like if uh acute
care might be kid running down the hall
and slamming their face into the door
they would have an acute care situation
something that needed to be taken care
of at the moment uh and that's uh uh ju
opposed against chronic which is just
like longterm if the kid has early onset
diabetes or something that would be a
chronic care situation I only I only
asked they terms of art y I only asked
that because I was referring to
represent Damon's comment about it's
similar to nursing their nurse so they
have they they have skills uh that deal
with that that's all they just think
some I didn't know if there SE I got it
thank you representative Bon thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious online uh nine
um it says providing leadership and it
did say in the profession and
professional nursing practice why why
are you striking out
profession um because it's just a
cleaner sentence and it make it doesn't
make it sound like there are additive
requirements when it's really just one
requirement to be able to Dem
Simplicity any other questions seeing
none thank you very much thank you and
Thomas thank you madam chair members of
the committee nice to be with you all
today my name is Sean Thomas I'm with
the m preol and Thomas here in conquer
and we have the privilege of
representing the New Hampshire school
Nurses Association um so I'm pin hitting
today we had a wonderful school nurse
lined up to testify but unfortunately
she couldn't make it at the last minute
so this will be brief and I'll do my
best to answer any questions but um
really just want you to know that we had
talked to representative Edwards very
early on during the LSR process um
this bill these are his ideas obviously
based on conversations he had with the
Auburn Village School and his ideas but
we very much support it as an
improvement to what is a very important
uh certification because and we support
it because it recognizes I think the
current Nur nursing shortage and the the
need for more flexibility so that's how
we view it we support it we think it's a
good thing and to the extent there are
any questions I'll do my best to try to
answer them any questions Mr Thomas uh
representative Damon then Mr Woodcock
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question nice to see you you
as well are you aware from The Nurses
Association
of other additional approaches that they
might like to address this shortage of
adequate School
nursing yeah so I mean that's an
interesting question so this is this is
an issue I'm sure many of you are
familiar with we've seen it now over the
last several years I think there's been
tweaks if not every year maybe every
maybe every second year um and I think
that's just the reality of the sort of
the nursing shortage and and things that
have transpired since co uh especially
but I think it's important the history
is important with respect to the
certification program it's relatively
new I mean so it starts back in
2016 it was actually a collaboration
with the Department of Education at that
time in response to complaints and
concerns regarding the quality of stool
of School nurses so that's sort of the
impetus that's why we have the
certification program now and I think it
serves it serves an important function
like representative Edwards said uh
there is a critical need for high
quality health care and that's really
what this establishes I mean if you
think about School nurses in a sense it
really is a
specialty
um they may be in most in most cases
here in New Hampshire the one Medical
Professional in the building they need
to respond to a number of issues uh make
quick informed decisions particularly
emergency situations and these are
things where really maintaining that
high standard is important and that's
really why we think the certification
program is important um and so to the
extent there are little little things we
can do to improve the to expand
flexibility or increase flexibility
while still maintaining that standard we
think that's a good thing and that's why
we support this bill and I think but in
terms of specific ideas Beyond this I
haven't heard any unfortunately but I
mean we're always open to ideas thank
you representative Woodcock thank you m
uh thank you so much turn thaning my
question I just want to be clear on what
you just said to representative Damon
yeah so is your position or the position
of the nurs the position of the Nurses
Association is that they are supporting
the doe certification requirement that's
correct yes very much so okay thank you
thank you m chair representative
Bon thank you madam chair thank you
taking my question um so I'm still
struggling a little bit with the
language on um lines 2 and three because
it doesn't appear to really change it
that significantly can you speak to how
that actually changes
it yeah so I think the concern among
some who um who apply for these
positions is they may have significant
experience in acute or chronic care
settings not necessarily in pediatric
settings
and they are kept out of applying or
becoming School nurses and so the idea
here is rather than Focus specifically
on on experience in pediatric settings
you would allow hiring folks who have
more acute acute and chronic care um
experience and that translates equally
well into the school setting as well
because at the school you're dealing
with those types of
issues followup um so so primarily
you're saying that the wording and
having acute and chronic care first will
help them in advertising the positions
to attract more
candidates uh I think it expands the
pool of available
applicants so you rather than saying
you're only eligible to apply to the
extent you have pediatric experience
this would if to the extent you didn't
have pediatric experience specifically
but had acute chronic ha experience you
could also apply where where maybe now
you wouldn't or you wouldn't be able to
be
hired representative Hall thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question sorry um so the word priority I
I'm I'm thinking it actually says they
have to have experience in a pediatric
setting because it's a priority how is
priority measured is that just like more
than anything else is that over 50% of
their
time you know what I mean it looks to me
like they have to have the Pediatric
experience yeah I mean that that may be
a a better question for representative
Edwards but I I guess when I when when
we looked at this and when I read this I
think it's sort of referenc in an ideal
situation where still there is some
pediatric experience um but I think the
change here is that acute or chronic
care experience is really what is
important pediatric would be would be a
nice plus but wouldn't be necessary I
think that's sort of how we read that
change can I have second question follow
up go ahead okay follow up second
question um The Lure versus
certification am I correct that
certification with the doe is every 3
years lure is every two years is that
right or did I read that uh lure is
every two years and I believe yes
certification is every three
years thank you representative Cornell
so do you think it's gotten more
difficult for districts to hire School
nurses when now that they have to be
certified by the Department of Education
and hold a license in nursing they have
to have
two licenses um which is more difficult
to get I I know that in Manchester
there's a shortage of School nurses um
and I think they're having a hard time
finding them because of the
certification and lure yeah I mean
that's that's a fair question and I I
will say I I think the given the current
circumstances the nursing shortage
issues I think that's contributing to
some of these issues I don't think it's
the certification specifically again
this goes back to
2016 there hasn't been a problem except
in the last probably several years and
my understanding is there are very
there's relatively few openings in
school nursing outside of the two big
cities Manchester and NASA and even in
those cases
I believe they're using agency nurses I
think that's really the issue in
Manchester and Nashville that's my
understanding
anyways they aren't allowed to use
agency well agency nurses aren't allowed
to leave the agency to be hired by the
school district so that's causing a big
problem too but I don't think it's just
in Manchester and Nashville I I think
it's Statewide the the so what from what
I've been told it's it's it's a a
handful or less than a handful outside
of Manchester asell representative C
thank you so much and thank you for
taking my question and if you don't know
the answer to this and want to respond
later okay um would this allow someone
who let's say graduated from nursing
school in December but did a like a I
don't know if they do internships and
nursing programs the way they do in
rotations thank you the way they do in
education programs would that person
then be based on this bill eligible to
be hired this week as a school nurse
uh that's that's a good question I
actually don't know specifically um doe
may know the answer to that question if
if they intend to testify I'm not sure
but I but this particular
bill I don't think changes the answer to
that
question
um again it's it's changing sort of the
experience requirement I don't know that
it changes with respect to new grad and
how and how all that intermingles I
don't think there's a change there but
again I I don't know for sure I'm sorry
thank we do have the opportunity to have
Steve applebe come up and ask her
technical questions do you have a
question for this gentleman okay
representative Damon thank you so I
think I'm understanding from the
discussion that line 23 in the proposed
language is saying that a person who has
three years of experience in either
acute or chronic
care not necessarily any Pediatric Care
could be hired for a school nurse
position however if there were other
candidates who had pediatric care
experience they would be given priority
is is that basically what it's saying
representative Edwards is nodding his
head to me then then that must be what
it's
saying no I no I I I agree I mean I I
think that would be a decision um the
administrator could make but I think
this this particular language affords
them that
flexibility any other questions Sone
thank you very much do we want to call
Steve applebe up thank you for any
technical
up all right good afternoon chair hi
Representatives Steven app Auburn New
Hampshire uh Department of Education
educator support and higher education so
I Heard lots of questions
fire away questions for Mr Apple uh
representative Cornell we'll kind of go
this way okay thank you for coming Steve
um are our teach are nurses finding it
difficult to get the certificate from Li
certificate from the Department of
Education um to go along with a night
license n yes thank you for the question
I would say based on the current
statutory language it is restrictive and
very often I have conversations with
superintendents around the Restriction
that the statutory language um States so
um for example um the the proposed
statutory language
removes pediatric nursing or other
related nursing areas that wording what
that means is we see applicants at times
whove worked in for worked for example
in retirin
home we can't say that's related we just
can't get there if they're working in a
retirement home as a nurse and they
apply for a license because now they
want to work in a school the current
statutory language says related area we
don't interpret working in a retirement
home as a related area so I would say
the stat current statutory language is
restrictive okay representative
Bon uh thank you for taking my question
um last year if I recall we made some
changes into those certification
requirements
um has that helped at all uh thank thank
you for the question um I would say on
balance no it hasn't made any difference
okay representative cig thank you I'm
sure you heard my question about the
newly graduated nurses um I just
wondered yes relates please yeah thank
you um the requirement is that they have
three years of
experience so if may I follow up sorry
if if that is as a a a student rotation
would that be considered sufficient
experience so we um I would have to seek
check with our legal counsel but on the
face of it that would sound like that
was experience gained before they held
their nurse their Registered Nursing
license and typically typically we don't
count experience in a role in fact we
have administrative
rule um to this fact that if you're in a
role that requires a license and you
don't possess that license we don't
count that experience towards that
license now in this instance whether or
not that would apply I'd have
to se advice representative Freeman
thank you madam chair thank you Mr
Appleby for coming in front of us I'm
sure we're going to have a wonderful
relationship in this legislative term um
I do have a question um for you about
some of the changes that I saw when I
was in the legislature six years ago and
one of them was about um the educational
requirements of School nurses it was
associates degree but then associate
degree nurses were grandfathered in as
of 2022 that as long as they had an
associate degree and when enrolled in a
Bachelor of Science um degree in nursing
they could be and completed that program
within six years then they could be a
school nurse um are you finding that
that particular administrative rule is
prohibitive for districts for hiring
nurses
um thank you for the question I would
say unbalance no I think that's
actually less
restrictive having that language so you
haven't seen any push back I'm sorry
followup I apologize Madam chair I have
my hand up all the time and you don't
see me so I'm just yeah yeah so you
don't see any push back from that
particular administrative role change
the only push back that I've witnessed
with regard to that change are
individuals who can't complete the
requirement that in the out of time okay
so they have an associates they get to
the end of that time period three or six
years and then they can't move forward
because they didn't get that bachelor's
degree very good thank you so much
representative Hall thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question so the example you gave about
the nursing home so the nurse comes in
and wants certification but if she's
been in a she or he have been in a a
nursing home then the language here was
says with a priority within Pediatric
settings this language wouldn't change
that at all right because they haven't
been in a ped pediatric setting um is
that right yeah thank you for the
question well it says a priority within
it doesn't say experience in right so I
would I would again seek legal advice
but my just back of the envelope look at
it would be this is less restrictive
than the current statutory language
follow up with you just the word
priority how do you see the word
priority in this language I mean it's
you have to have done it I'm not thank
you for the question I know you didn't
not an attorney but we would look at
that and say okay well if they have it
great priority it doesn't say they have
to have it we view that is less than a
must or
shall again I could be wrong I'm not an
attorney question representative
Woodcock thank
you thank you once again for being here
and helping the committee uh I'd like to
go back to your comment that you just
made to representative
Hall the priority piece
so if they don't have it they do have it
I I was trying to figure out it's the
local priority in hiring or you as a
certification but I I was getting a
different gist when I heard you speak
basically you're saying that verbiage in
priority doesn't mean anything because
it's it's just not necessarily reason
doesn't matter either happy or don't it
doesn't matter it's just a priority for
someone is that bear thank you I think
in in regards to lure for School nurses
through the Department of Education and
the State Board of Education the word
priority is not shall right so it
doesn't doesn't have I would seek legal
counsel on our end but okay thank you so
much thank you m chair any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much and I'm going to close the hearing
on HB 208
FN we're gonna
re regroup on what time
115 we're we're g to regroup at one
o'clock
e
welcome back everybody um uh we're ready
for our one hearing this afternoon with
it which is House Bill
68 uh making best interest placements
within the same school district
mandatory in the absence of a valid
reason to deny the placement and uh the
prime sponsor representative Lon is here
knows thank you Mr chairman for the
record I am Erica Leon representing the
town of Derry which is Rockingham 13 I'm
a third term rep and I got to spend my
first year with uh many people here on
education my bill is actually quite
simple it says that if a parent believes
that their student would do better in a
different School in the same district
the answer is yes unless there's a
really good reason to say no I think one
good reason to say no is if there's not
enough space in the classroom and quite
frankly if them moving in would mean
that there's not an open one open seat
for a kid who moves into that school's
territory during the school year that
would be a valid reason to say no right
now we do have best interest placement
which allows a parent to ask the
superintendent to move their student to
a different School within the district
or to one of the other options within
their school district in Dairy we don't
do any uh tuition or any out of District
placements for for sard students unless
it has to do with special education so
that's not relevant to my district
however best interest placement itself
does impact that in other areas but this
bill doesn't touch that it only talks
about the in District changes so we had
a situation in Dairy we had five
elementary schools we now have four and
the students from dairy Village School
were moved around to different schools
within the town the fourth graders that
were being moved were were in their last
year of Elementary these were the kids
who came in with virtual kindergarten
they were Mass through first grade and
half a second grade in third grade they
found out that their Beloved School that
perhaps their parents that attended as
well was closing and then they moved to
another school if there's not a good
time and a good reason to say yes to
most of the parents who are asking to
move their child to a different school I
don't know what it would be you had
students who wanted to follow a mass
specialist that they had finally come
out of their shell and were finally
doing a good job they want they had been
at the both been assigned to the same
school but they wanted they then with
the redistricting they were moved to
different schools when you have a
student who's shy and has a hard time in
school but has finally just started to
flourish I think it would be a simple
move to say that they can follow that
teacher who they have a really good
relationship with that request was made
and it was
denied there were other requests as well
I actually brought this up at tryouts
for little leag um there's a whole
broadc cross section of parents and I
was shocked at the number of parents who
had asked to have their child moved and
they were rejected by the superintendent
without without any explanation or
reason because that's what the current
law says it expects a lot of compassion
on the part of the superintendance and I
get that they have a hard job I get that
there's a lot for them to do but
accommodating our students should be
pretty simple that is why I filed this
bill the other issue too is that right
now when the superintendent doesn't
follow the law about what to do for best
interest placement it just drags on and
on and on the 10day require M to have a
hearing did not happen for many of these
students but there were no
repercussions this law would also say
that if the superintendent doesn't
respond and doesn't follow the law then
the request is granted I think that's
the least that we can do and it doesn't
go to penalties or punishments for the
superintendent it just makes that mostly
yes a definite
yes so this has no Financial impact
because these are schools within the
same district within that should under
RSA 1891 should be providing the same
level of Education same opportunity for
education at all schools within the
district I don't expect that this will
be because one school is good or one
school is bad I expect that a lot of
this will be about learning styles or
getting away from a
bully there's many reasons why a student
may do better at a different school
right now their main option is to either
apply to a charter school or leave the
public school system this gives them a
yes to move to a different School in
District staying in with with their
District staying with kids in their
community and getting to know more that
they'll see in middle school and high
school I think that this is the smallest
possible step to give more options to
our parents and students and I hope that
you will support
it thank you very much representative uh
questions for the
representative representative
Damon excuse me thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my
question does this
change student access to approved
private schools in District No thank you
for the question this does not impact
this this is only for IND district
schools the IND District public schools
and if there's something that we could
do to tighten it and make it clear that
it is only for the public schools and
not a private school that was my
intention when I asked for this language
for
OS yes
on line five and line seven it says
approved private
school so that's clearly not only Public
Schools I think that's a question oh
thank you I think you've had the same
experience of OLS not drafting things
exactly how you intended um I apologize
that I have put a number of bills in and
you're correct so we should strike that
a pro private school and it should only
be made to another public school or
public Academy I apologize for that
oversight and I thank you for catching
that further questions representative
SEL thank you and thank you for taking
my question so clearly in der you have
as you said now Four elementary schools
and I don't know how many middle schools
and high schools in your District um
outside of the so we have dairy we've
got Dober you know some of the cities in
the state um many of our small towns my
understanding is only have one school in
their District so how what would the
impact be on
a a district that has literally one
elementary school and maybe not even a
middle or High School within their
community that they they tuition to well
thank you there would be absolutely no
impact on them because you can't move to
another IND District school if there was
only one IND District school and in
Dairy it would only apply to elementary
school because along with Closing one of
our five elementary schools we also took
our two middle schools and turned them
into a 56 and then a 78 so this is why
comp passion for these fourth graders
really really was needed because I told
you about coming up to fourth grade now
they move into a 56 school then they
move into a 78 school and then they move
into Pinkerton which is a wonderful
school but is almost like a college
campus so these there's a lot of value
in consistency in education and I
recognize that moving from one school to
another is inconsistency but there's
bullies thank you our representative
Lichfield thank you and thank you just
curious in this particular situation
where you're mentioning it sounds like
there's an abundance of fourth graders
that may be unhappy how would that be
navigated are you thinking a lottery
system um thank you for the question I
would leave that up to the districts but
I think the most Fair would be just to
process them on a first in first out or
to have a lottery system um either to
pick one of the two because if you had a
whole pile in front of you and you could
choose which kids to accommodate um that
would introduce a a lot of problems and
a lot of questions so I would prefer to
allow the districts to either have a
first in first out or a lottery process
where they would set a date um because
Equitable represent
Woodcock thank you chairman Celli good
to see you
back good afternoon um I want to follow
up I I did I want to follow up on rent
Damon's question Le the the pot on line
seven was talking about the private
account of private school so you going
to request a couple questions I Mr CH
you going to request a change to that to
take that out sorry on line seven where
it says public school private Academy or
um private school within the district um
and you said that was not your intent in
the bill because obviously if they're in
the school district I understand that
part so are you going to file an
amendment to take that out uh yes I will
file an amendment to take out approv
private school um the public Academy is
like Pinkerton or Co Brown um and with
that in my town the only school we send
to is Pinkerton but I know there are
some schools where they have a number of
different options and Pinkerton is
essentially a public school even though
legally it is a public Academy so I
don't think it would be Equitable to
students in other sending towns that
have multiple options to exclude them
from attending Pinkerton so I will
remove the approved private school but I
think it's prudent to leave the public
Academy okay want follow follow thank
you ch um so just to fall off to that
then um going back to initial um uh
rationale for the bill that some
youngsters are legitimately stuck in the
school building that they shouldn't be
and then except for the seat capacity I
think you said there they should have an
option to go somewhere else within the
school district um I'm not suggesting
that's bad my question is why we want to
have the RSA that tell the
superintendent the local school board
how to how to manage their school
well thank you for the question we've
already given them the flexibility and
this is not just a dairy problem I heard
from people around the state that their
best interest placements are rejected
without a reason um this is about
accommodating students and as I'm sure
you're aware there is a mental health
crisis and we are seeing too many kids
dealing with bullying that take a
permanent solution to bullying um that's
one of the areas where a lot of times um
I've heard that a lot of superintendent
say stay there figure it out out you
need to figure out how to work with your
bully that doesn't always work and
providing this option for students to
change schools to get away from a bully
or even get away from a bad F friend
group because as you know sometimes you
may have made certain life choices and
then want to change what you're doing
and I'm not sure if every superintendent
will understand that a child has started
to run with a bad crowd they've decided
that they want a new crowd and the best
way to do that is to move schools that
is a very very valid reason to move
schools because that's the whole whole
the students whole future a lot is
determined by the people that you spend
time with and um and there's still an
opportunity for a valid reason to say no
I just think that for the for default
answer should be yes okay thank you
Freeman thank you um Mr chair and thank
you representative for bringing this
bill forward I I just a quick side note
before my question is um uh four years
on the m the school board I can't even
begin to tell you how many times parents
had requested that their children be
moved even under the Manifest hardship
and they were refused with no
explanation so this bill basically says
that um this is to address the lack of
the transparency around the rejection by
the superintendent is that correct that
is a large part of it yes thank
you representative
litfield thank you and thank you I mas
two questions start with one one okay um
well it prompted that my fault um okay
so my first question is I understand the
part about the transparency but it is
also stating that they they absolutely
must adhere to this correct unless
there's a spatial
issue so it says in number two that if
the superint the existing language is if
the superintendent does not find that
it's in the best interest of the student
to change the student school or
assignment the parent or Guardian May
request a hearing for manic Fest
educational and
um and within that it says within 10
days following such decision the
superintendent shall provide a written
report to the parenter guardian Pro Prov
providing the reasons why the request
cannot be accommodated so with that the
superintendent would need to say why
they are saying no to the request for
the the best placement change by knowing
the reason for rejection that creates a
better process for the Manifest
educational hardship and for the School
Board to actually know what is going on
um there may be some very very valid
reason why a student can't be
accommodated at a different school but
instead of saying my answer is no and
I'm not going to tell you why it
requires a superintendent to make that
information public and given that the
superintendents in are in charge of
running the school school district and
the school board is in charge of hiring
that that sole employee the
superintendent there should be that
transparency to say why the
superintendent isn't and accommodating
these
changes did you have another question I
did thank you uh just regarding
Transportation how would that work uh
thank you in the best interest placement
law it already says that the parent is
responsible for the transportation and
this would not change that perfect thank
you yes representative thank you chair
um
representative have you ever heard of a
study by shakel Anderson wolf in
2016 which shows that there are better
student outcomes when you provide them
with student choice and does that sound
um sort of consistent with what you have
already studied about school choice and
better outcomes for students thank you
uh thank you I'm not sure if I've read
that particular study but yes um when
you have the agency on the buyin to your
education and you're an active part of
choosing that path students are more
involved which leads to better outcomes
um quite frankly we do already have some
school choice options within the state
and this enhances the IND District
Choice which I think is really really
critical because if a student can stay
in the district but still meet their
needs then that that doesn't really
change much except that individual's
experience and um I think that it's both
economically sound and the right thing
Learners yes represent Terry thank you
um so so um I I've heard you reference
Derry and uh allude to other districts
um where there are multiple choices that
would be available as are not the case
in many smaller communities do you have
any sense how many families and students
might potentially benefit from um this
change that you're recommending um thank
you for the question I don't know the
numbers because a lot of people are even
afraid to speak out that they had asked
for these accommodations I put this out
on one of the more
uh vocal Community groups in my P my
town and some of the responses from
people on the Schoolboard and others
within sort of um one particular mindset
within the town were um very unkind to
parents who would think to move their
child from their assigned school because
there's other students who might not be
able to move and because some other
student might not be able to move and
have that choice they said that nobody
should have the chance Choice the
opportunity to move I found that very
very distressing it's almost like saying
that because there's people who can't
walk I shouldn't be able to walk um it's
it's quite an offensive statement to say
that you need to be locked into a
particular School based on your address
but because of that mindset and the
people that were piling on there's a lot
of people who are afraid to speak
publicly about their desire to move
schools um especially because it's seen
as anti-school or anti-teacher in order
to speak out about the challenges in
their town so I've heard from people
privately but I have not heard as much
publicly because people are afraid of
pressure thank you and thank you for
identifying the differences of opinion
that
occur uh amongst uh parents in in these
schools um but potentially what we're
looking at is that it would seem is a
significant number of families and and
students who might take advantage of
this because if I'm getting this right
correct me if I'm wrong we're looking at
all the districts that have multiple
elementary schools multiple middle
schools multiple high schools where so
where this could occur so that's a
substantial number that could take
advantage of of this if the bill were to
be passed correct uh based on space in
the other schools yes yes and I think
that that would be an important signal
because if a school has that many
families unhappy with what's been off
offered um then that school needs more
um attention from the school board and
the superintendent to make sure that
they're meeting the needs of those
families because if we have a school
that everybody wants to flee we have a
really big problem especially for those
students who can't move that school and
if those students that want to move
become those canaries in a CO mine and
let people know that people want out of
um I'll use my school which was an
amazing Elementary if everybody wants
out a Westlake Elementary because
they're having problems then that tells
tells you that it needs to be fixed for
everybody um I'm hopeful that that won't
happen but I'm even more concerned that
we won't have those signals and kids
will continue to stay in an educational
environment that lots and lots of people
want to live leave just because we don't
information any represent Damon thank
you Mr chair you mentioned at the
beginning of your remarks and thank you
for taking my question that lack of
capacity space Capac in a school could
be a reason that the request was
declined are there other legitimate
reasons that you've entertained where a
request would be
declined um thank you for the question I
can't think of them but I don't really
want to tie their hands there may be
some reason why it can't be met and
that's why the superintendent would need
to share that with the parent and the
school board because if a reason was
given and others didn't agree that it
was valid then there would be a process
to appeal and overturn that but I don't
want to tie the hands of the schools um
I'm not looking to mandate exactly what
they do I'm except for the fact that
they are to listen to the parents first
on moving their child um I think that
that is a pretty low bar of requirement
especially because those F because
families are able to leave the schools
already I want them to stay in
District because I'm an all of the above
school choice person I want really
strong public schools and I want a whole
variety of options and I think this will
Schools see no further questions thank
you very much representative thank you
and uh we move from a a representative
Lon welcome to the education policy
committee good afternoon chairman
members of the committee thank you for
having me um my wife's a tough fact to
follow um we both both have strongly
valued education which is where I think
this bill is coming from if I can very
briefly I I think it's worth mentioning
we have such a rich history in our state
with respect to education um three
people who I think everyone in this room
knows I'm going to go back to a book
from 1848 called the lives of the
signers of the Declaration of
Independence Josiah Bartlett was an
immigrant from Massachusetts it was a
separate State a foreign State um
um I'm from California it's just as bad
that um so what a lot of people may not
know there's Josiah Bartlet Center here
now but he was a troubled child he had
problems with education what worked for
him it was actually a hybrid education
where he drove his own education at home
after that family friends someone with
the last name of Wentworth who I think a
lot of people have heard I went to grad
school at Dartmouth um um pretty big
name in the state actually mentored him
he didn't do so bad at 16 he entered the
field of medicine which was not an
untypical age at the time that's what
worked for him um William
Whipple grew up a little poorer um he
was native actually born in KY New
Hampshire which is now kid
main he went to a public school which at
the time was called a common school a
school for commoners he absolutely
excelled there not only through hard
work but through the mentorship of his
parents
after school he wound up going out in
the ocean he was a seafer he and his
brother had learned enough they became
entrepreneurs and were very successful
after that the rest is history there I'm
focusing there's much known about them
I'm trying to just stick to their their
educational choices Matthew thoron was
actually an immigrant from Ireland a
little further away across the pond as
some of my colleagues in Ireland would
say um I don't drink whiskey so not let
others argue over where uh the best
stuff comes from but long story short
Matthew Thorton grew up in a very very
wealthy family when he immigrated here
he not only had no trouble getting into
Medical School his family name carried
him into medical school and the same
Governor Wentworth that was friendly to
Josiah Bartlett actually open doors if
you will um for Matthew Thorton so three
very important people in our history
three people that are very involved in
writing of the Constitution where we get
article 84 from oh sorry article 83 um
if we fast forward today today um just
going to share I've taught many things
I've taught scuba diving which is pretty
cool thing I've taught classes there I
was sharing with my wife on the way up
one of the best classes I taught was a
school was a class of death students and
apparently I did really well they
listened so well above water when we
went below there was no remedial
training needed that had never happened
it it was the easiest class I've ever
taught and then I had three more um they
were very different from some of the
other special needs students I've had
I've coached Special Olympics let me
tell you you see a special Olympian
crossing over the Finish Line he'll be
in tears it's pretty cool they're just
as excited when I see my son hit a home
run they're just as excited it's really
cool to see that's education and I was
only one person in their life I've
taught at The Graduate level I've taught
at the postgraduate level I still teach
medical medical education and
oncology um I've taught first aid ba
basic life support I've taught CPR to
firefighters in New Hampshire a wide
breath and one thing I can tell you I've
had a lot of amazing mentors every
single teacher has a different teaching
style everyone has a different teaching
style if you have any of you haven't
read a book called The Last lecture it's
worth reading put politics aside read
this last lecture this person was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer which
is an invariably fatal disease he gave a
talk that it it is uh it's breathtaking
or you can read the book or both um so
every teacher has a different teaching
style and I think we've all seen this in
our own personal Journeys so too does
every student and not all of them match
not all of them will
match this bill
provides a second set of eyes and if you
go back to our Constitution Article four
the right of conscious this preserves it
for the parents within our district
we've seen bullying we've seen politics
enter the classroom um some of the stuff
is absolutely amazing who better to
guide education than parents to say you
know what Junior's having a big problem
in school
X it could be the school it maybe it's a
great school just that particular
teacher or the culture at the school is
not a good fit for the student merely
switching them it changes things if I
can a quick example my two boys my
younger one who's 10 Eli you ask him his
favorite subject and grab a cup of
coffee because he's goingon to talk to
you about math thank
you his older brother Mike who is 12
he'll do math he used to hate math you
put it in terms of Aeronautics he loves
everything PLS I can't teach itics I can
gu I can guide them to someone who can
giving students the choice our Public
Schools we have some great public
schools now this provides a no cost
alternative for parents and students to
provide feedback within a district to
say a particular School a particular
teacher is performing well to fit my
students
needs I think as representative Le and
my wife testified earlier if there's
significant feedback about one school or
one teacher I hope we don't see that but
if that happens maybe that's something
to dis needs to evaluate this uh this
empowers parents to get give the optimal
outcomes for their own children I'm
happy to take questions thank you very
much any
questions I see none thank you very much
thank you kindly thank you for being
here um is there anyone else oh
that's I just want to go in front of you
see okay good afternoon my name is
Deborah how I uh good afternoon chairman
cordelli it's good to be in front of the
house education policy committee again
my name is Deborah house I am president
of the American Federation of teachers
New Hampshire and at this time I have to
speak in opposition of this bill if we
lived in an ideal School uh world where
all our schools gave the same
opportunity for a robust public
education I would be in favor of this
bill but since that is not the case in
New Hampshire even within the same
school district I have to speak in
opposition so um as we know every Grand
State child has the opportunity for a
robust public education no matter where
they we no matter what district they
live
in but well this just deals with uh the
opportunity within the same district
because our districts do not get
adequate funding for that robust public
education where students have small
class sizes all the academic and
behavioral support they need uh and
rigorous curriculum we have districts
that have to make choices they have to
do things like concentrate support
services for certain kinds of academic
or behavioral needs in certain schools
if a parent comes up and says you know I
feel it's in the best interest of my
child to be in another school and the
default answer is that the
superintendent has to transfer the child
you are possibly moving the student away
from the support services they need
because maybe those services are located
in the school the parent wants to move
them out of um you are
also forcing the district to say no to
the parent even though that may be you
know what they would um really like to
do is work as a team with the parent or
incur expense by having the support
staff travel to the school that the
parent wants to transfer the child into
or hire additional uh
staff if you are incurring expense for
the Local District isn't that an
unfunded mandate we had a little lecture
about that last week um for those
reasons the automatic assumption that
the district has to agree AG ree to any
request from a parent that the parent
say is in the best register of the child
I have to object to this um I also don't
see in here that there is anywhere where
the parents and the district work
together to try and solve whatever issue
has come up that makes the parent
believe the school is not the best fit
for the child um you know has there been
any attempt to solve the issue within
the school before transferring I I
understand the example where the school
is closed there's no working around that
but um in many instances the school is
still open and is there any interim step
in
between um there's a lot of concerns
with this bill there's a short timeline
10 days for the superintendent to turn
it around um it seems
to be asking a lot of our school
districts to reply to requests and and
not giving them a lot of room to work
collaboratively with families and that's
when students get the best results when
parents and the school Community
teachers administrators superintendents
work together all focused on the best
interest of the child so for those
reasons I have to oppose this bill as it
is written and when we have great Public
Schools all across the St state in every
District and every school within the
districts then we can talk about having
Universal school choice thank you and we
oppose this Bill thank you yes
representative thank you
chairman thank you for uh taking my
question in your opinion would this bill
have any effect or influence on our
smaller neighborhood
schools it would have some influence um
I know where I work some of those
smaller neighborhood schools had
concentrations of
support um for
students so you might have parents
saying well I want to move my child out
of there to a different School in the
city in Nashua because you know the test
scores don't look so good so maybe it's
not such a good school but then you will
be moving your student away from a place
that actually
had smaller class size
and a lot of academic support and into a
bigger school where they didn't get as
much individualized attention if you
look at on paper the test scores in the
smaller neighborhood schools actually
you know might be a little bit lower on
the aggregate but your students getting
more support so
um
yeah you also have to be able to make
sure a conversation is going on and that
that there is a good exchange of
information
before an
made follow um also in reference to this
I was thinking about title one so if I
have a title one student that moves from
a title one school I guess that person
would have to go to another Title One
school but they might be requesting it a
school that is not so the services is
what I was thinking oh yeah they
wouldn't get if they went to a different
school that didn't have whole school
Title One funding title one it's a
Federal grant that provides academic
support and uh they would not get the
same level of support if they went to a
school that did not have the same
percentage of students living below the
poverty level so there will be fewer
adults in the school to support their
read their reading learning um or to
support their math
learning thank
you yes representative McDonald thank
you chairman and thank you um the prime
sponsor mentioned a constitutional
provision that requires all districts to
provide equal opportunities at all
schools within that district and I know
that for a fact the case in my district
where we have five elementary schools
and they all have comparable education
but you reference that may not be the
case Statewide are you aware of a
district where there's that's not true I
know there are districts where they have
concentrations uh you know through
through different grants they have
concentrated support for students with
different needs learning needs in
specific buildings so if you were to
move your student away from that support
they would have a difficult time getting
those learning needs met unless the
district were then required to have
staff travel which incurs an expense or
hire more staff either way you you know
now
putting an unfunded mandate on the
district to meet those students needs if
I may have a follow-up question my
understanding of this bill is that if
the superintendent finds a valid reason
then they don't have to accommodate the
request is that not your understanding
well valid reason is not defined so when
something is very open-ended like that
you don't know what's included and
what's
not so you're you're leaving it open to
interpretation which can be very um
dangerous
because we may agree but it's not
written down is
it if I may the prime sponsor indicated
that spatial issues for example may be
something that constitutes this and I
would agree I would understand that what
you suggested if they are specializing
perhaps English Lear language learner
students at one school special needs
accommodations at another I would
recognized that that is
also a valid reason would you not agree
with
that we would hope that that would be
recognized but it also could lead to
more lawsuits are you comfortable
funding that from
here are you
asking from from the state treasury you
fund all the lawsuits
right yeah yeah you know we'll address
the questions this okay well um yes
represent Freeman
take thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question so if one of the scenarios I'd
like to work up and get your opinion on
is if a child is being bullied
relentlessly and all the modalities have
been utilized to address that bullying
with the with the person who's allegedly
doing the bullying the child the parents
and there's there's no resolution to it
and the child may be in visible danger
would you think that would be an
appropriate reason to Grant the request
to move that child to a different
school with the hypothetical youst that
sounds like a classic case of manifest
hardship and I believe those have been
granted I I can't speak in every
instance but that does sound like one
that fits that um that statute Mr CH may
have a follow you may thank you so much
would you believe that actually I do
know requests that have been refused in
spite of manifest education hardship and
these were the exact scenarios thank you
yes represent Morris than uh thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking the
question uh so the wrong person just to
kind of wrap it up and
um the subject of math for instance
let's say you know we got two Geniuses
sitting here in the room right and let's
say they're in their current elementary
schools don't offer the same curriculum
as let's say the next Elementary School
within the same district maybe the other
curriculum is a little bit harder and
more challenging for the student so and
it seems to me that this this big for
instance would be kind of like a last
choice for when all negotiations fail so
that way the parents have the ability to
send their kids the school that would
best challenge their needs at that
time am I wrong I don't see anything in
here about all negotiations failing
either so that that part would certainly
need to be uh stated a little more
clearly and um you to get back to a
previous question having different
curriculum in different schools in the
district is not something that I have
encountered so with the exception of
high schools that sometimes
offer like in nsha North High School
might offer a class that South doesn't
but the students do indeed uh go back
and forth if there's a class they want
take it one and they they attend the
other um but they don't transfer schools
uh they just travel for the one class um
there's a bridge between them you can
walk um but
um I do not know of any districts that
have like a different curriculum at the
elementary level in one school than
another
So you you're asking a hypothetical that
I don't know there's any place that does
a a situation like that Magnet School
type thing again you want to fund every
school so they have a Bo curriculum then
can have them start specializing and
have magnet schools so you solved the
first problem we'll work on the
second yes Ros
har uh I noted that among the uh several
uh objections uh that you cited with
respect to the bill that you mentioned I
recall unless you correct me uh for
having misheard that uh the
10day uh 10day specified here following
the decision being made was a short
turnaround time and I'm just trying to
understand um if a decision is made
presumably there's a reason why the
decision was made and I'm wondering why
it would take more than 10 days to
communicate a decision and the reason
for the decision and if it's not enough
time why would it not be enough time and
how much more time do you think would be
uh ideal to allow for a decision of no
you yeah
that yeah I I'm just going to withdraw
that I
um I was speaking not looking at my
notes of and I was thinking it was a
10day time to make the decision and
communicate not to communicate once you
made the decision so I got ahead of
myself in in my thoughts there so um yes
thank 10 days would be short to go
through the whole process but not to
tell people once you have made your
decision you are correct thank you very
much for that um any further question
questions uh seen none thank you very
testimony um I think we have one more
up
sorry thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee Jerry F Associated
executive director New Hampshire school
administrators Association I had not
planned to testify uh on this bill but
several questions came to mind during
listening to testimony that I just um
would would think that it's important to
have as part of the discussion uh
determining what to do with it um the
word shall seems to suggest this little
discretion um in the in the
decision-making process and um certainly
uh you know folks want to do uh what is
is in the best interest of kids um a
valid reason suggest I'm not quite sure
what valid reason means and and I think
about this from the perspective of a
superintendent who was in a Regional
School
District um we had one school board but
seven towns and so if someone from New
London wanted to send their child to
Warner because the parent worked in
Warner and that was the the valid reason
uh to want to transfer a child to
um Simon school would that have to be
accepted this whether or not the
population at Simon school I'm going to
say fourth grade uh had 15 students in
it when um perhaps the the New London
school had 15 but 15 in one Schoolhouse
and those of you that have been in
education know well 15 students in one
classroom can pres present one of
um issues and 25 students in another
classroom could be very easy to deal
with and not present any issues at all
and so I'm wondering does the discretion
does a valid reason be that that's those
children that that classroom that you
want in mner is filled with a number of
disciplinary issues and frankly your
child in the Judgment of the Educators
is better served in the class of 25 in
New London because there are no
discipline issues there achievements
high so what's the valid issue is it the
parents work need
and I'm all about collaboration we are
all about collaboration with parents and
trying to make the best Solutions but it
would seem that we need a little bit
more Direction in something like that um
and that was uh you know parents deserve
explanations I agree with the the the
bill sponsor parents deserve
explanations plain and simple um 10 days
representative plenty of time if if this
body says 10 days it's 10 days it's 10
days we can do that that's not an issue
um so I just like would would ask that
you contemplate a little bit more
definition around what's a valid reason
and and compelling the
shall the shall can be problematic and
representative Bon oh thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question I
have um some questions about student
privacy issues having served on a school
board um in my hometown for many years I
know that whenever we had um special
education issues or issues with students
that were requesting manifest hardship
or transfers all um there literally is a
wall put between the administration and
the school board members we are not
entitled to have that information um do
you see any privacy student privacy
concerns in this thank you
representative for that question I do
see some uh some potential priv student
privacy issues because if the
superintendent um was required to to
make the placement um they might know
based on the knowledge that they have
that that's not necessarily a great
placement for an additional child but
you can't say it's not a great placement
for any additional children because we
classroom thank you resident
Woodcock good afternoon again M um
couple things in the bill I just want
your opinion on it I I agree with
representative Leon that that this may
be a reasonable solution for boying um
100% and sometimes that's the only
solution um but I have a concern that
there's a lack of specificity when it
talks about how many times during a
school year a youngster can move I'm
concerned about um what time in the
calendar you're going to allow that
movement if it shall be whatever they
request it um and the third one I'm
really concerned about I want you're
just quick syop those three three the
third one I'm concerned about the the
the all the data we have on learning
that happens with youngsters who have
multiple transfers to schools and the
lack of in the there so could you give
like a thumbnail on those three issues
in your opinion from being
superintendent thank you for the
question representative Woodcock
certainly the number of transitions in a
school year and the time of those
transition I play a definite role in not
only the the achievement and the
opportunity for that student that's
being uh transferred in but also the
kind of the Dynamics if you will of the
classroom and the and the rest of the uh
um the rest of the students and I would
also have concern again I'm going to go
back to the regional district Conway
being one um sa6 Regional type things
when you take a child during the school
year and and move them to a another town
so to speak and change the the
Friendship group change the Dynamics
that that takes adjustment time um for
everybody um and I I think that studies
I can't cite the studies but I think
good Common Sense would say that it
would be a disruptive piece and
thank you thank you Mr chair any further
questions see none thank you very much
oh I'm sorry representative litfield
thank you and thank you for taking my
question so am I hearing you correctly
that if we set certain parameters around
this where the change would take place
let's say whether it be the beginning of
an academic year or let's say after the
winter break the Christmas break excuse
me that that would be best and that
would be and and I just want to take it
a step further I'm looking at this um I
see pros and cons in this definitely I
can see both sides but we have someone
here that is saying I support school
choice but she's trying to keep it
within the public school system so I
would think we would want to support
that that's my concern so I'm just
wondering what we could do best to serve
this sure thank you for the question
representative
LEL
um it's going to sound like a cop audien
I think probably to some around this
table but I think local decision- making
is really important there um as a
superintendent we accepted a high school
transfer because of a bullying incident
after the first quarter of a school year
with a neighboring School District just
a handshake between two superintendents
yeah let's get this done um best
interest of the kid kid graduated from
our high school
and lived happily ever after I guess I
don't know but there's a certain level
of even within our district there was
there were policies that would allow
inter inter uh Town transfers so I guess
what I'm saying is that the local
decision-making process can deal with
some of these things uh and because they
know what's best that at that point in
time
um thank you very much uh seeing no
further questions um thank you very much
for your testimony thank you and um
we'll close the hearing on uh HB 68
um and we'll take a few minutes uh break
session
e
so you're gonna act as the vice chairman
[Music]
right okay
okay okay we will get started with our
um exec session um we have several bills
to
discuss
um and we'll start off with uh HB
384 which was a u bill regarding uh
prohibiting
bullying um we have two more uh bills um
one of it one of which came in um just
recently regarding bullying also so what
I'd like to do is um hold this
one
um uh I'll double check
um uh the uh due date on it um but hold
this and get the other two done and then
maybe have a work session uh to talk
about the three bills and what we
actually need to do in terms of bullying
I know some people had some concerns
with some of the provisions in
384 um so we can talk over the three
bills and see what we actually want to
do um on the
subject
okay
um uh no don't have to yeah don't have
it um the next one
is uh talk about HCR 6 the one we heard
this
morning
um I think um I would like to hold on
this one also um I missed some of the
testimony um especially in regard to
court cases um I'd like to go back and
listen to that um as um a couple of
other people um and I think that there
are some uh
legal ramifications since it is in the
courts and I want to um research more
about um what happens with a house
concurrent
resolution um so I'll do that research
and then reschedule um this exact
session
also represent of Hall uh thank you Mr
chair so you're not this isn't this is
just holding it to get more research
it's not holding it to get a decision or
anything like that correct okay thank
you
um so uh let's go back up to the top um
or what I have as a top on mine anyway
um which is
hp71 um related to uh School
shelters and I'll look for to
representative NATO for a for a
motion thank you uh chairman Celli um
yeah I do uh want motion is s to
pass okay do I have a second I'll second
that okay um representative NATO do you
have a
discussion yes Mr chair um just a small
uh observation of uh mostly uh safety
for most vulnerable the children and
also the staff uh in regards to what may
or may not be brought into the the
school
uh as far as
either uh drugs weapons uh viruses
disease where they're not inoculated in
coming into this country uh we have no
idea so it would some be something that
we would have to really take into
consideration uh thank you uh the Secor
any
comment no okay no thank you
um any discussion then on the uh bill
and the motion of represent
baboni uh yes um I would not support not
to pass it all on this bill uh first of
all is talking about Emergency Shelters
um the schools are often used for
emergency shelters in weather advents um
and who is responsible for checking the
status of those seeking shelter um when
you are in an emergency shelter
situation the children are not in school
um so I don't understand the concern for
uh children's safety in the schools at
that point um And in regards to some of
the other um statements that have been
made regarding
disease um one of the provisions of this
bill if you read the fiscal note it is
going to cost the state of New Hampshire
12 to18 million annually and loss of
federal funds it violates federal civil
rights
laws um as uh the US Housing Department
of Housing and Urban Development does
not require citizenship documentation
for certain
programs the term specified aliens seems
to include all
non-citizens including permanent
residents green card holders and persons
with refugees status these people are
all entitled to be here legally and um
this bill is prohibiting them shelter in
emergency
situations further comment
representative Woodcock thank you chair
Kelli um I don't know the intent of the
theot maker of the motion but the other
concern I brought up during the hearing
I'll bring up again that we have uh uh
many schools that are available in the
summer
um an open that could be used for
emergency shelter and I don't know why
when I asked this the spokesperson that
wasn't there um it was sort of like a no
you can't use it at all um my my
question is there are every school I
mean I'm thinking my own Community we
have five schools two of I know are
doing the year summer so I to the open
so just why we why would we prohibit
every school district saying you can't
provide emergency shelter when you have
emergency fac is there that doesn't make
much sense to me I mean where we are
regardless of who's supposed to be in it
thank you thank
Cornell okay represent Morris uh thank
you Mr chair
so this bill isn't talking about banning
people with green cards and whatnot from
being able to access the schools online
11 through 12 it specifically States
specified alien means an alien as
defined in section 101a of the
immigration and nationality act 8 USC
section 101a who has not been admitted
defined yes go ahead
I thing I have no idea what the hell
that means can you tell me what that
means I can from that immigration just
ask I don't yes so an illegal alien who
came across the border without any
documentation and entered into our
country illegally so that's what
specified
definition representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair um you know
in in support of this I will tell you
that um on a more personal my late
husband worked 15 years for immigration
and and and Customs Enforcement and I
will tell you the definition between
alien illegal and Asylum Seeker and at
this point the only people that would
qualify as legal in this country are
green card holders refugees and anyone
with an up to date Visa the people who
are not here legally for whatever reason
are the Asylum Seekers who used the CBP
p app over the past four years they have
not been vetted they have not been put
through into Pole to see if they are in
fact wanted criminals they have not been
petitioned by the United States
government to their country of origin to
see what their criminal backgrounds are
they have not been medically cleared
this bill addresses those individuals it
does not address or prevent Refuge
housing legal aliens anybody with a
valid Visa or a green card we have seen
instances in Massachusetts and New York
and I personally saw in instance Logan
Airport last year at the international
terminal they had it Cordon doed there
was
500 Asylum Seekers behind a petition in
the international terminal of Boston
Logan Airport now you tell me how safe
anybody would feel in that situation you
want to put someone who's not been
vetted through the United States
government for whatever reason into our
Public Schools even if the children
aren't there you are exposing them to
potential crimes potential diseases
potential viruses so this bill is more
of a proactive instead of a reactive
situation so we aren't faced with making
that decision they had an instance in
Roxberry Massachusetts with the mayor of
Boston put all of these Asylum seekers
in the only Community Center they had in
rockberry that is an impoverished pot of
Boston that is loaded with minorities
those parents were absolutely wild they
took the only source of community away
from their children in the inner city we
want to prevent that this is what this
you repr
SEL with all due respect to quote the
current governor we are not
Massachusetts and the things that are
happening in Massachusetts and the
things that are happening in New
Hampshire are different this bill in my
opinion is an offensive bill I would
never support something like this I
think we need to recognize that people
who have come here by whatever means
they have come here are generally
fleeing from situations that are dire
and desperate and if we're so concerned
about diseases we should not be working
on other bills that take away the
ability for people to get inoculations
and vaccinations and we should be
requiring anyone who walks into any
vaccinated
hear uh representative Morris did you
have another comment it yes this is in
regards to a situation that happened to
me a few months ago from an illegal
alien when I was actually assaulted and
attacked from someone who did not obey
our laws because they didn't know what
our laws were I was down in South
Carolina yeah I know it's not New
Hampshire but I was helping with Storm
Restoration from the hurricane we had
and there was an legal who was drunk
driving got into a hit- and run accident
and then took off I was on the train
tracks trying to help an 18 wheeler get
through before a train was coming so I
was kind of
preoccupied it was a long story um
the guy in the vehicle came back and I
took his keys out of his ignition
because he was definitely drunk um he
couldn't speak English we were trying to
get a translator app open and he
proceeded to assault me and I had to
defend myself against him um these are
the type of people that are coming into
the country they don't have a law book
that they go by they're not raised here
they don't know what's legal and what's
not therefore they don't abide by it so
if we allow these people into our
schools community centers or whatever
else we're subjecting our society to
really anything I mean they could be
putting cameras in the girls bathrooms
we don't know what the capabilities are
but the options are endless so yeah as
to the point preventative let's make
sure that we can keep our communities
safe as our top
priority representative
Damon thank you Mr
chair with respect to the different
scenarios that are being reported in
other parts of the US
and particularly representative Morris
the unfortunate South Carolina
experience none of these are things that
Americans don't also do so the idea that
we are blaming
immigrants for drunk driving and
assault as if they are somehow
different is
extremely
oh yes I'm going back to the term
specified aliens according to the New
Hampshire um uh Health and Human
Services office uh that term is not
defined and they use the closest match
and when they were describing the the
financial impact of the bill which is
the word alien What refers to any person
who is not a US citizen or national and
because of that that it can be assumed
that it would include all
non-citizens this bill doesn't specify
that it doesn't include people with
refugees thank you representative Harvey
bolia thank you Mr chair
I the bill is um yes it that is true
that is not um specified in that way but
the refugees have a refugee program that
is some of the documentation I gave you
the office of refugee and
resettlement that's where the refugees
go for housing and they have programs in
pretty much every state is my
understanding uh the the Genesis of the
bill is to keep the schools for the
students um and to protect that
vulnerable popul pop ation of the
students where we've seen a lot of
encroachments um we've lived through
covid when they close the schools and we
don't want to close the schools again
and I don't see that that is mean
you repres Corell for other than the
fact that this is a mean bill um the
Health and Human Services did say say
that because of the different um things
that we would
be acting against that Government
funding could be withheld and it could
be 12 to 18 million per year and they
also said that according to rules you
can no longer say um indeterminable that
cannot be used as an excuse anymore no
matter what um former commissioner
Steven said who's been out for about 20
years um so we could lose 12 to18
million a year in a year when our budget
is not in good shape and my second point
would be that it prohibits the use of
public schools it doesn't say public
charter schools which you know has to be
included um because of the statute if
you don't mention them they aren't
counted so our public charter schools
could be used um if if the word worst
case scenario happened and we had to
house somebody so they would all go to
you sure um represent Terry yeah with
respect to the fiscal note and the loss
of federal funds um I I I would like to
uh point to the current reality that we
actually are now beginning to see more
people leaving the country than coming
into the country so I I don't I'm not
quite sure uh upon what premise this
fiscal note was developed but the
situation has uh changed markedly since
January 20th thank
you I would just note um there was an
article in uh NH
nhpr um see the date uh January 23rd um
of this year about um flights of
refugees headed to New Hampshire um were
cancelled after the president's um
executive order um we will not know what
will happen in the future um there could
be uh legal action um related to that uh
executive order uh so um so I I will
support um the motion any further
discussion representative Bon yes um
thank you uh what what you're saying is
something that's in the future what what
a what the Health and Human Services
have said to us is that's the funing
that they are currently receiving it's
unclear I mean I think you're making an
assumption that the refugees that we
currently have are somehow not going to
be here anymore because this money is
going towards them and with regards to
another comment that was made about uh
the housing being available for refugees
sure they have as part of the program
housing but the same as you and I if
there is an emergency in our houses and
we have to seek shelter why wouldn't
they be in the same boat as the rest of
us thank you Mr
chair uh representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair and I this
this will be my last comment I pulled
this right up out of USCIS law so any
alien who enters their attempts to enter
the United States at any time a place
other than as designated by immigration
officers or two eludes examination or
inspection by immigration officers or
three attempts to enter or obtains entry
to the United States by willfully false
on misleading representation or the
willful concealment of a material fact
shall for the first Commission of any
such offense be fined under Title 18
that is the definition of an alien a
refugee is not a definition of an alien
a legal alien is not definition of an
alien and somebody with a green card or
a Visa that's in good standing is not
the definition of an
alien okay um thank you all um m Adam
clerk
um are you
about ready with the
yes okay and the motion is ought to pass
correct house
bill um 71 okay motion is ought to pass
today the
27 okay all
right chairman cordelli yes
representative har bolia yes
representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative
litfield yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative NATO
yes representative Cornell
no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no Representative
bbon no Representative selig no
Representative
kuger no and representative Damon
voting right because of absence mhm
correct okay great um thank you um will
there be a Minority Report yes they
will
okay Sor um what's today Monday yes how
week um the is next week the 6th yes it
is yes it is okay so how how about
Wednesday
morning it's only Monday right and yes
Monday right and the motion uh for the
this thank you very
much and the next bill is HB
129 and uh do I have a a motion um
representative dry yes i' would like to
make a motion ought to pass thank you is
there a second I second that
representative
McDonald um would the maker like to uh
speak to her
motion yes I just want to say that I
have heard the term evidence-based a lot
in the last two years I like the fact
that it's being addressed and that's why
I'm supporting
this uh representative any comment yeah
to say it briefly I like this bill
because it incorporates a scientific
method into the education system with
the concept of
falsifiability and then just finally it
doesn't prevent anyone from using
surveys or conducting surveys just that
that has to be declared as self-reported
data as opposed to evidence based by
this
definition thank you further discussion
anybody representative Woodcock thank
you chair Kelli just um surprisingly
enough I won't be agreeing with that um
my my think my thinking is a couple
things the first is um I understand
representative uh process for this but
I'm concerned that we this eliminates
the chance for improvement in pedagogy
by uh new Innovative attempts because
they may not have a whole record of Base
we would not be able to go forward in my
mind in education over the years if we
didn't continue to relook and reimo
nothing in technology we didn't relook
reimo and gets better every day I mean
so to say nope we're going to stay right
here we are at 2025 and call it a day um
and you know the i find I find that um
not in the best interest of Education or
students and I'm not suggesting the
content that the content the way the
content is defined is one thing but this
is pedagogue is how do we teach this
that's the H from ballpark I think
you're limiting teachers and their
ability to be professional instructors
thank you thank you representative C
thank you very much I I agree um with
representative Woodcock that my concern
with this is that it it blocks the
ability
for um school districts to
test out new teaching techniques that
are being developed I think back to when
I was teaching when laptops started
becoming or computers in general we had
to go to a computer lab initially um and
then we got laptops that came to the
classroom on carts and that was all very
new technology and very new strategies
when we started incorporating those
things into our teaching style and
teaching students work processing as
part of their editing process and not
just pure editing by handing a written
copy that their friends had to decipher
their handwriting which you know if
student was like me with disg graphia
their handwriting was completely
illegible um and so I I think about the
ways and the speed with which our
society is developing in the time since
we have added technology to our
classrooms things are changing faster
than we can think them through and I
just feel that this type of a bill
stifles the ability if we have to only
use established practices we won't be
able to develop new practices and so for
that reason I can't support this Bill
thank you representative representative
B Bon uh yes I also will not be voting
in favor of this there's something that
um my work as a member of the
professional development uh or what we
used to call Professional learning
communities in my school district um
relied a lot upon what we call Best
Practices best practices are what
teachers are doing in the classroom and
they share those ideas if I'm in a group
of fourth grade teachers and we are
teaching a unit um I rely on my peers to
help um analyze what I'm doing in terms
of the way that I'm teaching but also
suggest things and that's what teacher
mentors do this spill is interfering
with with the way that schools and um
professionals work with each other so I
can't support this
spill thank you representative any
further uh discussion representative
Damon thank you Mr chair one more
dissenting voice over here for all the
reasons that have been stated and also
it is yet again downshifting cost to
it thank you see no further comments um
Madam chair Madam
chair now that was that was a little
ready uh this is um ought to pass motion
on House Bill
129 related to uh the term
evidence-based in public
education chairman cordelli yes
representative Harvey bolia yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative
litfield yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morse yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
Representative bbon no Representative
selig no Representative kuger no
representative Damon no 10 Y and seven
Nays and one not
voting and uh an itl motion for the
minority
represent
SEL great um thank you very much I think
that finishes our business for today and
um uh you can have the day off tomorrow
but we'll be back at it uh with a full
day uh starting at 9:30 I believe on
Wednesday
time do they start do you have
chocolate okay just for the record
education funding tomorrow's
meeting
um and I think we have just hearings
scheduled for Wednesday but a full
day thank you everybody